So, da brauchen wir 17 Monate, Huge Subscriptions, das ist ja schon richtig, wo hab ich's?
Nice, bisschen leiser machen, oder irgendwas entspannteres machen.
Moment, es gab, stimmt, Alter, kann ich wieder, auf der Wii gab es ja so eine Wetter-App.
Genau, der Wii-Wetter-Channel, ja, das wisst ihr mal, da hab ich schon wieder voll verdrängt,
stimmt, lull. Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel.
Nee, nee, ich bin aufgestanden grad, vor einer halben Stunde oder so, ungefähr.
Exzellent, richtig exzellent. YouTube hat mir heute nur Müll empfohlen,
zu 90 Prozent, zu 98 Prozent, nicht alles, aber zum größten Teil war nur Müll dabei.
Gucken, wenn ich jetzt refreshe, ob da was besseres bei ist, ich find's ja schon mal
gut, dass ich meine eigenen Videos empfohlen kriege, vor allem das Video, wo Geralt einfach
nur rumsteht, seit zwölf Minuten. Discord, ich kann jetzt grad nicht ins,
Moment. Hab ich Discord auf dem zweiten Rechner hier
am Start? Nö, 0w, oder? Ah doch, ice.
So, in welchem Channel hast du was gepostet? Ja, post noch mal hier.
Aber nur, wenn's wirklich big brain exquisite Video ist.
Guck dir das Video von Hardwarerad an, die haben den echt gescampt, wirklich?
Ich stelle mir eigentlich Hardwarerad sehr schwer zu scammen vor.
Leere Pakete, wir wurden beklaut? Was? Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt mal kurz angucken.
Ich guck's mir gleich an. Ich scroll erst mal schnell YouTube durch.
Die wurden beklaut? Na gut, aber ich hoffe, der kann denen auch
das Geld wieder klauen, was er schon bezahlt hat.
Hoffentlich mal zumindest. Okay, Captain Peng, mal gucken, was ist das?
Ach, der Jahresrückblick. Ich bin wahrscheinlich einer, aber ich kann mir
Videos, ich guck mir Videos von ihm nicht gerne an.
Kann ja auch nicht genau erklären warum, aber irgendwie hat's da nicht so, nicht so
gefruchtet. Ich guck eh so gut wie keinen deutschsprachigen
Channels. Ich weiß auch nicht warum, wahrscheinlich
ist YouTube Deutschland bei mir einfach im Kopf zu negativ vorbehaftet, dass ich mir
keine deutschsprachigen Videos angucken kann, weil ich dann automatisch an Crap YouTube
Deutschland denke, obwohl das Video gar nicht schlecht sein muss.
Vor 13 Jahren. Wobei, doch, komm, wir können uns das ruhig
nachher angucken. So sieht aus wie MW2.
Warum drückt mir YouTube eigentlich jeden Tag Corona News aufs Auge?
Es ist ja nicht so, als würde man nicht schon eh genug davon mitbekommen.
Und dann ist es auch immer, ist es immer die gleichen üblichen Verdächtigen, ey.
Warum zeigt der nicht mal die Bild, Alter? Wenn schon übertrieben, dann richtig übertrieben.
Die Steam GUI einfach die GPU zu 60% außer, das sollte die Steam GUI aber eigentlich
nicht machen, auch wenn die Steam GUI ein Browser ist.
Also die YouTube Empfehlungen sind wirklich ziemlich pepega heute.
Also das find ich auch geil, ne. Lego lernt ja aus den letzten Shitstorms
nicht. Wahrscheinlich haben die einfach zu viele
Big Stonks Anwälte da hocken. So, wir gucken jetzt am Anfang mal eine
Runde Battlefield. Wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt.
Übrigens, ey, das wollte ich euch noch zeigen. Ich will mir das Video nicht angucken, das
wollte ich euch nur mal kurz zeigen und zwar. Könnt ihr euch dran erinnern, dass ich mich
immer über diese Grafikkarte lustig gemacht hab?
So, und jetzt lerne ich gerade, meine 980 TI, die ich hier am Start hab, ist rare.
Ich hab eine rare 98 TI hier. So ein Teil, so ein Teil hab ich am Start
hier. Ihr müsst euch mal den Namen anhören, ihr
müsst euch mal den Namen anhören, von der Grafikkarte ist der beste, bester Name aller
Grafikkarten aller Zeiten.
Ja, das Teil hab ich am Start. Da hab ich mich doch schon öfters über den
Namen lustig gemacht. Vor allem, das Ding hat eines der abgedrehtesten
Designs, die ich je bei Grafikkarten gesehen hab.
Mal gucken, ob er es zeigt. Genau, du hast hier an der Seite noch einen
Lüfter. Guck mal, du hast hier an der Seite noch
einen extra Lüfter, der dann reinpustet. Das ist nämlich der Airboss, darf man nicht
vergessen. Also die anderen Lüfter nicht, aber das hier,
also genau das hier ist der Airboss. Warum weiß ich nicht, aber das ist der Airboss.
Wo ist meine Musik? Wie gesagt, das Video müssen wir uns nicht
angucken. Ich find's nur witzig, dass das eine rare
GTX ist, die ich hab. Rare. Zu Diablo 2 Zeiten dachte ich noch, es heißt
Rare. Kein Spaß. Aber Diablo 2, da hab ich auch, zu Diablo 2 Zeiten hab ich auch noch
nicht gedacht, dass Ocarina of Time, Ocarina of Time heißt, sondern so was wie Ocarina
of Time oder so. Ich konnte das alles nicht richtig aussprechen
damals. Und kam dann Diablo 2 eigentlich raus.
890 oder so? Oh nee, nee, da muss das vorher gewesen sein.
Da war ich immerhin schon 16. Wobei, kann durchaus sein, dass ich mit 16 einfach englische
Wörter nicht aussprechen konnte, schon möglich. Manche sagen ja, es wäre immer noch so.
Der Chat freut sich ja jedes Mal, wenn ich Englisch reden muss.
We are all sitting in one boat. Der ist der Airboss, weil der Lüfter ganz oben
sitzt. Wahrscheinlich. Doch, der macht was. Ich hab den aber ausgeschaltet, den Airboss,
weil der Airboss, Moment, wo ist der? Weil der Airboss genervt hat mit der Lautstärke.
Ich glaube, ich hab den relativ sicher den Airboss ausgeschaltet.
Aber diese Geschichte mit we are sitting in one boat, das ist ja nicht von mir, das hat
er der Oettinger damals erzählt bei seiner Antrittsrede zum, was war der Oettinger nochmal?
EU-Kommissar für Digitalisierung oder irgendwie sowas? Moment, was war der Typ? EU-Kommissar
für Digitalwirtschaft. Der Typ hat in seiner Antrittsrede damals erzählt, in my homeland
Baden-Württemberg we are all sitting in one boat. Und das hat sich bei mir irgendwie eingebrannt,
dass man auch mit nicht ganz so gutem Englisch so eine Position kriegen kann. Da ist ja für
mich schon nicht alles verloren. Und weil ich finde, es ist immer richtig Gewöhnungssache.
So, erster Tag, das heißt, wenn sich der erste Tag Gamescom war oder so, da tut man sich
immer übelst schwer, aber am zweiten Tag geht's eigentlich. Und wisst ihr, was auch
immer richtig schlimm ist, erster Tag Gamescom, für Leute wie mich, mir tun immer die Waden
übelst weh, weil du kannst ohne Probleme so 17 Kilometer da an einem Tag auf der Gamescom
rumlaufen, das geht, das ist gar kein Ding. Und da tun mir immer übelst die Waden weh
nach dem ersten Tag, weil ich das halt nicht gewohnt bin, 17 Kilometer am Tag zu laufen.
So, ab dem zweiten Tag geht's dann lustigerweise. Leider kann man die erste Nacht nicht so gut
schlafen, weil die Waden weh tun. Vielleicht kennt's ja noch irgendjemand und vielleicht
ist es auch die Kombination aus, ein bisschen zu schwer und ein bisschen zu alt für den
ganzen Scheiß mittlerweile. Aber gut, zumindest am zweiten Tag geht's dann immer ganz gut.
Kann man sich Gamescom überhaupt noch geben? Keine Ahnung, ich war die letzten Jahre auch
nicht mehr da. Jetzt die Gamescom war ich, was weiß ich, 2016 oder so, 2017, 2009, 2011,
2017 oder so, ist ewig her. Es sackt voll. Es macht, es macht meiner, meiner, wie, was
war, ey Leute, was ist eigentlich aus der Gamescom 2020 geworden? Die sollte doch rein
online stattfinden, oder? Und die hat dann, die hat dann glaube ich auch rein online stattgefunden
und absolut keine Sau hat sich für den Gamescom Stream interessiert, oder? Ich hab nichts
davon gehört, nichts, noch nicht mal zur Zeit, wo Gamescom war. Ihr geht wirklich davon aus,
dass im August 2021 wieder Gamescom ist? Da hab ich nach dem aktuellen Ablauf so meine
Schwierigkeiten das zu glauben. Okay, ja, das war übelst, das war übelst lame, da hat
keiner drüber gesprochen. Letztendlich muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen, ich finde, dass
es eigentlich auch keinen Sinn macht zur Gamescom zu gehen für Games. So durfte es jetzt klingen,
ne? Zur Gamescom kann man gehen, wenn man sich mal mit ein paar Leuten wieder treffen
will, die man lange nicht gesehen hat, oder wenn man vielleicht ein paar Leute live sehen
will, die man, wo man übelst fanboyt auf YouTube oder so. Vielleicht, dafür macht es vielleicht
noch Sinn. Aber um auf die Gamescom zu gehen, um sich Games anzugucken, ist die Gamescom
eigentlich der komplett falsche Platz. Du kriegst in einem Livestream, oder sei es im
Zweifelsfall einfach nur, wenn man Gamestar News oder so liest, oder sich die passenden
YouTube-Channels anguckst, du kriegst online noch nicht mal zur Gamescom Zeit, so allgemein,
du kriegst einfach die besseren Infos und bessere Eindrücke von den Games als auf
der Gamescom. Der einzige Vorteil von der Gamescom wäre ja theoretisch, dass man Entwickler
was fragen kann, bzw. dass man die Spiele selbst mal ausprobieren kann. Das Problem
ist, das kann man nicht, weil keiner hat Bock für irgendein 0815-Cut-Game drei Stunden
anzustehen. Und großartig mit dem Entwickler reden kannst du auch nicht, weil die ersten
grad Zeit haben, zweitens wahrscheinlich keinen Bock haben und drittens an den Ständen halt
irgendwelche Marketing, nein das stimmt nicht, irgendwelche Dudes, die zumindest nicht allzu
viel über das Game sagen stehen können. Also im Prinzip ist auf die Gamescom geht ziemlich
sinnlos. So und der einzige Grund warum ich ein paar Mal auf die Gamescom gegangen bin
ist, weil wir im Vorfeld, wir haben das ja tatsächlich jedes Mal, außer das erste Mal,
wo man auf die Gamescom gegangen sind, recht gut geplant, also ganz, ganz merkwürdig für
mich, ja, also wir hatten ja wirklich Google Docs Dokumente, wo wir uns die Termine gemacht
haben, aufgeschrieben haben und sonst war es. Das war auch ganz gut, dass ich da nicht allein
hingefahren bin, das heißt wir konnten uns da parallel drum kümmern. So und der einzige
Sinn war, weil wir im Vorfeld Termine gemacht haben und dementsprechend halt auch in Ruhe
was sehen konnten, ja. Das war der einzige Grund warum die Gamescom sinnvoll war, ansonsten
konntest du das komplett vergessen. Toll für'n Arsch. Und selbst da kam ja nichts großartig
bei rum. Ne, also ganz ehrlich, man guckt sich, man ist besser beraten, wenn man sich
den Livestream anguckt, bin ich. Außer man steht auf das Event und möchte mal wieder
ein paar Leute sehen, die man lange nicht gesehen hat und so. Dafür ist die Gamescom
gut, aber ansonsten für Games ist die Sack die Gamescom. Ich bin ja eh der Meinung,
die sollen einfach die Gamescom in Frankfurt machen, da ist mehr Platz und es ist bei
mir um die Ecke. Hey, Frankfurt Messe, ich glaub' Frankfurt Messe und Hamburg Messe oder
so, ich glaub' waren die zwei größten, oder Berlin Messe, Frankfurt Messe, Hamburg Messe,
ich bin mal nicht ganz sicher, waren glaub' ich die größten in Deutschland. Cosplayer
haben, stimmt, ja, ja, wenn man gerne cosplayt, dann kann man das auch machen, ja klar. Ich
glaub' ich geh zur nächsten Gamescom als Ayaya-Cosplay, als, als, ich geh' als Pepofet
Ayaya. So, machen wir das. Warst du eigentlich damals undercover dabei? Nein. Mit dem M-Core
war ich ein bisschen unterwegs, ja, aber das, äh, war ein paar Jahre später. Der M-Core
hat, ich überleg' grad, hat der immer noch meine Capture-Card oder hat er mir die mittlerweile
zurückgeschickt. Das ist auch schon 5 Jahre her oder so. Ich glaub' die hat er mir mittlerweile
zurückgeschickt, ich bin mir aber gar nicht mal sicher, ehrlich gesagt. Es könnte sein,
dass er die immer noch hat. Ja, hab' mich irgendwann gefragt, wollt ihr irgendwas auf?
Es gibt ja oben in der Gamescom, in dieser, das ist nicht in der Business Area, in diesem
anderen Teil, da wo es auch diese, diese ekligen Gamescom-Frikadellen gibt, ähm, da gibt's
ja so einen Raum, wo man Videos schneiden kann und so was, so'n größerer, so'n größerer
Raum, wo auch mit Schließfächer und so was. Da hat mich der, hat mich der M-Core mal gefragt,
ob er eine Capture-Card haben kann und ich hab' gesagt, ja klar, nimm. Die hab' ich dann
irgendwie nie wieder gesehen. Obwohl ich glaub' mittlerweile hat er mir sie wiedergeschickt.
Du mein' Stonks Area? Ja, genau. Dort, wo man die Black Ops Fast Passes kopiert. Erinnert
sich noch jemand da dran? Obwohl da ja auch hinter der, hinter der, wie soll man sagen,
hinter, hinter der Bühne sozusagen auch noch Dinger gelaufen sind. Oh man, Gamescom ist
echt so'n Ding, das ist total sinnlos. Okay, also was, wo fangen wir an mitzugucken? Okay,
zeig mal her, was gucken wir uns an? Wir gucken uns das Hardware-Rat-Video an. Wir gucken
uns das Hardware-Rat-Video an. Ich will wissen, wie sie ihn gescampt haben. Ich hoffe, dass
er seine Kohle wieder kriegt. Erst mal schön gescampt worden. Zu leise? Jetzt aber gut,
oder? Ska-Mars? Äh, Moment mal, er hat was? Ah, gewürzelt. Ich hab' grad was anderes
verstanden. Exzellent. Gute Idee, das mit der öfteren Überwachungskamera zu machen.
Ohne Scheiß. Sonst können die dir nachher erzählen, du hast's rausgenommen und bemerkt,
die sind ja leer. Da ist keine Ware mehr drin. Also Nachnahmepakete sind ja Pakete, die bezahlt
zuerst bei Erhalt. Also wir schicken die ab, wir haben noch gar kein Geld, wir schicken
die ab, geben sie an DHL. DHL bei der Übergabe an den Käufer kassiert dann das Geld ein,
man zahlt dann in bar. Jetzt gerade halt in der Filiale war ja... Ja gut, Nachnamen hab'
ich glaube ich die letzten 10 Jahre nicht mehr gemacht, aber es gibt immer noch Leute,
die machen das. Wegen Corona diese Postausfahrer das nicht mehr machen und deswegen müssen
wir in der Filiale abholen. Das heißt Nachnahmepakete kommen direkt in die Filiale und dort müsste
er eigentlich dann der Kunde hingehen, dort bezahlen und dann kann er das Paket mitnehmen.
Und die wurden halt nicht abgeholt, also Lagerfrist in der Filiale überschritten, wurden wieder
zu uns zurückgesendet, aber hatten keinen Inhalt mehr. Aber Verpackungsmaterial, das
war noch drin. Okay, das muss ja dann irgendjemand von der Post gewesen sein, oder? Also scheinbar
wurde die Ware rausgenommen. Das eine Paket war eine Grafikkarte und das andere Paket sollte
eine Grafikkarte und Arbeitsspeicher drin sein. Moment Leute, Chat, ich muss mal kurz testen,
was der tägliche POG-Champ ist. Immer noch der von gestern, okay. In beiden Paketen hat
der Inhalt gefehlt. Interessanterweise, die beiden Pakete hatten verschiedene Empfänger,
allerdings eben vom selben Ort. Also die gingen in den selben Ort, das ist ein kleiner Ort
mit rund 2000 Einwohnern, nicht sonderlich groß. Hat die in DHL gescampt? Und die Empfänger,
die haben auch nicht irgendwie in der Nähe gewohnt, hatten selbe Nachnahmen und so. Es
waren halt einfach so komplett verschiedene Empfänger. Danach haben wir die Pakete erstmal
untersucht und dann ist uns aufgefallen, die wurden ja neu verklebt, die Pakete. Und jetzt
nicht von so einem DHL-Klebeband, was typischerweise kommt, wenn Pakete beschädigt sind. Also DHL
hat so ein eigenes Klebeband, wo quasi draufsteht, Waren neu verpackt, damit man weiß, DHL hat
das neu verklebt. Nein, das war ganz normales Klebeband. Man hat halt ein Paket, oder ja,
man hat auf jeden Fall ein Paket. Chat, warum reagiert keiner auf den ICQ-Sound? Und eine
Einschnittstelle gesehen, dass da jemand mit dem Messer falsch angesetzt hatte. Das heißt,
da war oben so ein Messerschnitt noch gut zu sehen. Richtig Skammerisch, ja. Wir haben
den Kunden noch mal zu schreiben, weil, wie gesagt, man hatte ja schon mal in der E-Mail
hinterlegten Bestellungen geschrieben, ob sie es wirklich haben wollen. Die existierten
dann nicht mehr. Die wurden schon gelöscht. Das heißt, auch so kamen nicht wenig an den
jenigen. Aber wie geht denn das? Der Typ, der muss ja dann zu DHL sein, den Kram abgeholt
haben, das rausgenommen, wieder verklebt und DHL zurückgeben, so nach dem Motto, nehme
ich nicht an, oder irgendwie so, geht das? Das ist ja Big Brain-Scam. Naja, die Namen,
die da angegeben waren, die haben es ja nie bestellt. Doch dann, drastische Wendung.
Sehr interessant, weil wir haben noch mal aus dem selben Ort eine Bestellung über Nachname
bekommen und diesmal auch wieder eine Mobilbestellung und so eine generische E-Mail-Adresse, wo
wir auch schon... Na, zum Glück sind ja die Scammer meistens auch nicht die hellsten.
Wir haben gedacht, das ist er. Und jetzt haben wir auch die IP. Das brauchten wir aber gar
nicht mehr, weil ein findiger Mitarbeiter von mir hat genau aus diesem kleinen Ort
zufälligerweise die Grafikkarte gefunden. Also jemand verkauft exakt diese Grafikkarte.
Das ist ja frech, alle. Das ist ja richtig frech. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, er hat die
bestellt, abgegriffen und bei sich daheim ein Gelding-PC eingebaut. Aber nee, der hat
immer den bestellt und dann auf Ebay verkauft. What the fuck? Interessant, weil dies eigentlich
rare Ware. Was ist mit den Leuten los, Alter? Dem Hersteller. Zum Glück sind die Scammer
nicht sonderlich Big Brain. Komisch. Ja, Polizist dann angerufen, denen jetzt die neuen Sachen
geschildert. Scammers. Okay. Low-Brain-Scammers. Es wird ja wahrscheinlich sein, ich kann
jetzt aber nicht einfach so eine Hausdurchsuchung anordnen. Ja, das geht nicht. Weil es besteht
ja immer noch die Möglichkeit, dass er es nicht ist und wir können nicht einfach so
in... Bei so einem Fall können wir jetzt nicht einfach in Häusern von Leuten reinstiefeln.
Das geht nicht. Naja, Moment. Moment. Das ist ja auch geil, ne? Aber wenn du eine CD
kopiert hast, dann kann das natürlich schon mal sein. Ist ja auch klar. Wenn du einen
Händler um 2000 Euro scamsst, ist es natürlich nicht wild. Aber wenn du eine CD kopierst...
Okay, das magst... Ich weiß, das stimmt nicht. Das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen übertrieben
ausgedrückt. Das passiert ja beim CD-Kopieren auch nicht.
Habe ich gesagt, wir müssen uns da sicher gehen oder sicher sein, hat der Polizist gesagt
so mäßig, ja, ich kann ihn nicht auf eBay an... Mal ganz davon abgesehen, der Polizist
kann das ja eh nicht entscheiden. Das muss ja den Richter entscheiden. Also der Polizist
kann ja eh von sich aus nicht sagen, wir machen jetzt eine Hausdurchsuchung oder nicht.
Schreiben und den was vorgaukeln, dass ich Kaufinteresse hätte, das durfte ich als Polizist
nicht. Aber sie... Ja, und dann auf eBay Kleinanzeigen mal angeschrieben. Ach, der hat es auch noch
über eBay, über Kleinanzeigen. Okay, dass es authentisch wirkt, muss natürlich deine,
wissen wir ja alle, muss natürlich deine Nachricht mit wasletztepreis anfangen.
Wir haben Interesse an der Grafikkarte, du hast ein paar Bilder, wir kennen die ja überhaupt
nicht, ne. Der Hersteller sagt uns auch gar nichts. Bilder bekommen, einmal von einer
der Grafikkarten, wie sie eingebaut ist, und dann noch ein Bild. Vom PC. Und der PC ist
original von ihm zusammengebaut, ne? Einen Grafikkartenkarton. Hm, er hat also doch zwei
Grafikkarten, woher die wohl kommen können. Vor allem, bei der rachen Ware aus dem kleinen
Ort komisch war. Das Bilderweise war die Seriennummer nicht zu sehen. Also geschrieben, ey, ja,
ist jetzt ein bisschen wenig, wir haben sie jetzt bloß so eingebaut, von der Seite gesehen,
und die Kartons, das hilft uns. Zum Glück, zum Glück sind die Scammers doof. Hast noch
ein paar Mehrbilder, bitte. Der so, ja ja, mach ich, wenn ich zu Hause bin. Okay. Weiß
nicht, hat er dann mehr Bilder geschickt, und auf einem Bild, wunderbar zu sehen, die
Seriennummer. Zum Glück sind die Scammers so dumm, Alter. Aber immerhin, ganz dumm kann
er nicht sein, er schreibt sie groß. Direkt, äh, geguckt, an den wahren Eingang, ob unser...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wo er das nachgeguckt hat? Ich weiß nicht, ob die es noch verwenden.
Jetzt hat er in dem Tool nachgeguckt, was ich programmiert habe. Ob das eine Seriennummer
von uns ist? Gucken Sie durch, gucken Sie durch. Ich hab für die so ein Scanner-Tool
programmiert, wo du wahren Eingang Barcode-Scannern kannst. Keine Ahnung, ob sie das noch verwenden.
Die Seriennummer, die gehörte mal zu uns. Die Karte lag bei uns mal im Lager, und ansonsten
aus diesem kleinen Ort ist zu keinem so eine Karte hingegangen. Der Scammer, zum Glück
sind die so doof, Alter. Also dementsprechend, das muss er sein. Wir waren uns zu 99% sicher,
das muss er sein. Sehr interessant auch, der Typ hatte schon mal bei uns was bestellt auf
seinem richtigen Namen. Hat es auch ganz normal bezahlt gehabt. Da war alles normal. Aber man
hat ja, man sieht auf eBay Kleine Anzeigen Namen in zenzierter Form, und das hat mit
einer anderen Bestellung genau aus dem Ort auch total zusammengefasst. Geil. Und somit
hatten wir auch die Adresse klar. Wir haben auch auf eBay Kleine Anzeigen nochmal nach
der Adresse gefragt, aber damit hatten wir dann eigentlich schon die Adresse. Den Polizisten
so weitergegeben, und er so, ok, jetzt gibt es zur Staatsanwaltschaft weiter, und versucht,
dass ein Durchsuchungsbefehl kommt, oder dass man, ja, dass man einen Durchsuchungsbefehl
hat. Es hat dummerweise ein bisschen gedauert, also ich glaube knapp eine Woche. Ja, bis
dahin hat er den Scheiß doch schon verkauft, Alter. Leute, wenn ihr eine CD kopiert, wenn
ihr eine CD kopiert, oder, oder noch schlimmer, auf der falschen Porno-Seite euch einen Film
angeguckt habt, dann geht das mit den Sachen aber schneller, da dauert das keine Woche,
da wird der Richter nachts rausgeklingelt, und er sagt, Alter, oder, schreib irgendwas,
lass mich in Ruhe pennen. Eine Woche, bis dahin ist die Grafika noch schon weg.
Ja, oder so, und wir mussten den ja ein bisschen bei der Strippe halten, ne, so hat auch ein
Mitarbeiter vorgegaukelt, dem bis letztes Jahr war das, hatte der einen platten Reifen,
ne, und dann wollten wir dem so vorgaukeln, so, ja, also er so, ja, wir kommen's dir abholen,
dann so, ah, heute wird nix, und hat das alte Bild rausgesucht, und hat mir das dazu gesendet.
Nice, richtig big brain time, richtig big brain time.
So, ah, heute wird nix, und dann der Verkäufer auch noch fragt so, ja, kann ich verstehen,
dann, einfach... Ja, das ist aber scheiße, wenn das eine Woche
dauert, ne, bei jedem anderen, kack, geht das, aber da nicht.
Na gut, die sind auch ausgelastet, ja. Ob das heute noch klappt, und so weiter, ja,
auf jeden Fall. Erstmal CD kopiert, Sonnereinsatzkommando
gestürmt, ein Tag später an dein Haus, eh. Also, er war auch sehr nett, und so weiter
beim Verkauf, will ich, will ich nicht sagen, bloß wir haben ihn halt dreistangelogen, dass
wir Interesse an der Grafikkarte haben, aber müssen natürlich auch schauen, dass, dass
wir das jetzt nicht abrechnen, und er die Grafikkarte mit irgendjemand anderes weitergeht, sondern
dass er die wirklich zu Hause behält, dass wenn die Hausdurchsuchung kommt, dass er dann,
ja, dass die Polizisten alles vorfinden. Ja, und dann, kurz vor Silvester kam morgens
ein Anruf, Polizeiposten, der bei mir in der Nähe, hab ich, hab ich schon auf dem Handy
gesehen, ich geh rein, hab ich angerufen und gesagt, jo, Hausdurchsuchung war, wir haben
die gestohlene Wahldurchsuchung gestellt. Nice, nice.
Boah, hab ich mich gefreut, also ich hab mich... Wahrscheinlich geht's ihm gar nicht so sehr,
wir haben jetzt irgendwie die 1000 Euro oder 2000 Euro, bestimmt auch, sondern einfach,
dass man den Typ erwischt hat. Ich hab mich alles drüber gefreut, dass die
quasi, ja, die Ware sichergestellt haben, beziehungsweise, dass sie... Man merkt auch,
dass sie sich in Freude. Und als ich das an meinen Mitarbeitern erzählt
hab, ist erst mal ein Freudenschrei ausgestoßen, weil wir waren ja alle voll hyped bei dem Thema,
und also, ganz, ganz interessante Geschichte, wir wollten auch unbedingt, dass es aufgelöst
wird, ja, und am Ende hat's geklappt. Da bleibt aber noch die Frage...
Dazu können wir bloß sagen, dass wir jetzt auch... Moment, wo ist das passende... Wo
ist mein passendes Emote? Das verwende ich so selten.
Oh, oh mein Gott, oh, oh mein fucking Gott. Okay, weiter.
Am Ende, wie? Wie hat der das gemacht? Das wird mich auch interessieren, das wird
mich auch interessieren. Also, das Einzige, was mir einfällt, ist, hingegangen, aufgemacht,
rausgenommen, zugemacht, und dann DHL gesagt, ach nee, nehm ich doch nicht. Will ich nicht,
nehm ich irgendwas, irgendwie muss das doch funktionieren. Oder hat er sich ins Lager
reingestellt, von DHL, irgendwie? Mir wurde es so erklärt, also, die Postfiliale,
wo die Pakete eingelagert waren, gehört zu einem Supermarkt dazu, oder ist in dem Supermarkt,
und der Täter hat durch sein Umfeld quasi Zugriff auf den Supermarkt, wahrscheinlich
außerhalb der Öffnungszeiten... Ah, okay, das ist doch ins Lager gestellt.
... so Sachen aus den Nachnahmepaketen rausklauen. Was man auch gesehen hatte, was dem Polizisten
aufgefallen ist, richtig interessant, also ihr kennt es ja, wenn man an der Filiale ein
Paket abholt, die sind ja in Regalen drin und oftmals sind die Pakete außen beschriftet,
damit die Filialmitarbeiter schnell wissen, wenn ein Kunde kommt, ah, welches Paket ist
es? Das heißt, sie tun es ja oft noch außen beschriftet, damit man es am Regal direkt sieht,
von wem das Paket ist. Bei mir zum Beispiel ist...
Ich wusste ja, fünf Monate, danke schön. Bei meinem lokalen DHL-Station ist die Straße
aufgeschrieben, da kann man sagen, ja, ich wohne in der Straße, und dann steht sie direkt
auf dem Paket auf, dann können sie es schnell rausziehen. Ja, und da hatten sie auch was
draufgeschrieben, und der Polizist hatte das dann bemerkt später, hat mir ein Foto geschickt,
ja, diese Aufschrift haben sie die draufgeschrieben, weil die wurde überklebt, die Aufschrift.
Ja, und dann so, nee, die ist meistens von Postfilialen, damit die halt schneller wieder
erkennen können, zu wem das Paket gehört, wenn jemand abholen kommt. Ja, und das wurde
tatsächlich auch nochmal mit Klebeband überklebt, diese Schrift. Ja, und darin konnten wir uns
auch nochmal merken, dass es, wann es überklebt wurde, ne? Also, damit ist schon mal der...
Aber jetzt mal im Ernst, also eine Sache hätte nicht funktioniert, hätten die das nicht selbst
gefunden. Also, im Prinzip war ja die Polizei beim eigentlichen Rausfinden komplett useless.
Die haben das ja alles selbst gemacht. Das Einzige, was die Polizei dann halt gemacht
hat, ist, so quasi ihre Rechte genutzt als Polizei in die Wohnung von dem Typ rein und
durchsucht. Aber wäre der Scammer nicht so dumm gewesen, wäre der Scammer nicht so blöd
gewesen, wäre das Ding jetzt weg und es hätte keiner was gemacht. DHL-Pakete anliefert,
schon mal direkt aus dem Schneider, weil der beschriftet es nicht. Das heißt, es muss
auf jeden Fall schon in der Filiale, die Ware musste mal in der Filiale gewesen sein. Also
sehr interessant, wie sich das Ganze aufgelöst hat und ich bin natürlich auch jetzt am Ende
sehr glücklich, dass wir dann die Ware wiederbekommen. Wann weiß ich noch nicht, also ich weiß
nicht, ob die Polizei die noch braucht als Beweismittel oder so, oder ob sie uns die
dann einfach zurückschicken. Das wird sich ja dann noch zeigen. Weißt du, er müsste
sich jetzt erstmal aus Prinzip einen PC mit der Grafikkarte bauen und bei sich daheim
hinstellen. Einfach nur, weil es geht, ob er ihn braucht oder nicht. Dass er immer dran
erinnern wird, wie er den Scammer outsmarted hat. Einfach nur heif, wo das die Sache aufgelöst
wurde. Das wars dann aber auch mit dem Video. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Falls ja,
gebt dem Video einen Daumen hoch. Wenn ihr wollt, lasst ein Abo da. Dann bis zum nächsten
Video. Nice, nice, nice. Mal gucken, was bei ihm Windows 10 kostet. Ach geht, ist ja fast
so günstig wie Software Kong. Vmware Key 17 Euro. Ich bin verwirrt, wo habe ich meine
Musik? Mal dahin machen. Wiederfinden. Ja, aber zum Glück war der Scammer so low-prane
und hat es nicht gecheckt. Ein Hardware-Rad Vmware? Ich glaube nicht. Guck mal mal. Also
ich habe da noch nie was bestellt, aber ich kenne den Besitzer so ein bisschen über YouTube,
wie man sich da halt kennt. Wenn ich komplett PCs bestellen würde, ohne Mist. Ich würde
bedenkenlos da bestellen. Also sie geben sich wirklich Mühe und auch Preis-Leistungs-Medien,
was drin ist, kannst du da echt nicht meckern. Ob die Vmware Lizenzen haben, ich glaube nicht.
Ja, geil. Top. Man hat im Video eben richtig angemerkt. Die Webseite sieht übrigens besser
aus. Normalerweise die Webseite nur wegen meinem Darkreader so aus. Was hat er da oben
links? Ist das da oben links ein Vodafone-Icon? Oder was ist das? Was ist das da? Was ist
das? Moment, Moment. Zoom? Lens? Moment, wie macht man die Lupe überhaupt an? Windows?
Nee, was war denn das? Lupe? Leute, ihr wisst das? Windows Z oder so? Der Bildschirmlupe
kann ich nicht suchen. Ah, excellent. Das ist was? Muss ich jetzt overanalyzen? Ist ein
Shop ein Sexshop? Aha, das ist das Icon vom Shop. Ok, verstehe, verstehe. Nice. Echt nice.
Ich finde es aber cool. Das haben sie echt big brain gelöst mit dem Scammer. Top. Kingdom
Hearts aus Jakan sein? Nein. Ist Metroid. So, aber nice. Excellent, excellent. Da müsste
ich jetzt eigentlich auch mal drunter schreiben, Leute. Ich schreibe da jetzt auch mal drunter.
Aber der hellste war der Scammer auch nicht. Hä, ich bin gar nicht eingeloggt? Warum bin
ich nicht eingeloggt in meinem anderen Browser Fenster Sign in? Hier, anmelden. Melden Sie
sich bitte erneut an. Ja. Mach ich, mach ich. Alles gut. Eingeloggt. What the fuck? YouTube,
please switch account. Max FPS. Auch nicht Max DPS. Einfach nur.
Ähm.
Da, mal gucken ob das YouTube das Comment gecheckt hat, wo ist mein Comment?
Ja, genau. Also der Hälfte war der Scammer ja echt nicht, man merkt aber wie sehr du dich zu Recht darüber gefreut hast, dass du ihn in den Wicht hast.
Was ich auch geil finde, das find ich echt geil, eine Woche warten bis die Polizei was machen konnte, hätte der eine CD raubkommet, wären die Nachtsverhubschrauber dort eingestiegen, da hätte er keine Woche drauf warten müssen.
In einer Woche wäre der Typ schon 5x durchsucht worden für die CD.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass die CD-Keys die er verkauft legal sind, ich glaube nicht, dass er irgendwelche Scammer CD-Keys verkauft.
Okay, nächstes Video, schauen wir uns jetzt an, das ist ein Video, das wird mir schon öfters vorgeschlagen, das wollte ich mir mal angucken und zwar kann sich noch einer an Machinima und an Machinima Respawn erinnern?
Das interessiert mittlerweile ja echt keinen mehr, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt, gibt es gar nicht mehr, oder?
Ah doch, WTF, warum sind die, warum, die hatten einige Skandale, die hatten einige Skandale.
Die sind aber komplett weg, okay gucken wir uns mal an, wo die hin sind, Machinima Respawn, das war damals, wo die ganzen Quickscoper ihre krassen Montages hochgeladen haben, bevor Faceclan und Optik und alles.
Jawoll, oh Trickshot, Scheiße, Alter, last nice, only last nice, Leute, last last nice.
Da ist es, das ist es, das ist doch, das ist doch wo er so ausraste, das ist das Video.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht das, das war aber auch auf Highrise.
Nein, nein, Machinima hat es, Machinima hat es richtig verkackt.
Sys OXFF, nee, Null, XFF, nee.
Okay, können wir gleich noch mal gucken.
Die hatten doch, es gab, der erste Skandal um Machinima, wo ich mich dran erinnern konnte, ist, dass die so komische Verträge hatten, so Scam-Verträge, das war das erste, dann ist ja dann irgendwann, das ist doch auch das wo, wo, wo Hutch und Sinanus und so damals gewesen sind, der ist ja dann später übelst durch die Decke gegangen mit hier Trouble and Terrorist da und auf seinem eigenen Channel und sowas, die sind dann irgendwann weg, weil die keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß hatten, dann, ich weiß gar nicht ob Machinima was mit dem Xbox,
Skandal damals zu tun hat, wo die Leute Geld gegeben haben, die Xbox gut zu bewerten oder ob das nur Microsoft war, ach, die haben, die haben schon viel verkackt.
Ja, genau.
Ich bin da selbst gebrannt, wie nennt man das, Gebranntmarkt, wie auch immer was, was Scammy YouTube Netzwerke angeht, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass mein aktuelles YouTube Netzwerk sonderlich gut ist, ich hab mit denen glücklicherweise nicht all zu viel zu tun, aber zumindest scammen sie die Leute nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie mein aktuelles YouTube Netzwerk heißt, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Es war mal, es war mal GameInside, dann war es TubeOne und dann war es, jetzt ist es glaube ich DiviMove oder so, ja, ist es nicht da wo sogar Dagi Bee ist, ach du, ich glaube ich muss da mal weg, naja, wie dem auch sei, ich war damals in einem Netzwerk auf YouTube, die haben uns richtig auch versucht zu scammen mit so komischen Verträgen und sowas, da war ich auch doof und hab's nicht gecheckt.
Ey, der ist vier Jahre vor mir drauf.
Was?
Ne.
Ja, wobei es jetzt eigentlich egal, eher fünf Jahre vor mir.
Mr. LordKris, witzigerweise, hatte ich sogar schon zwei mal mit denen gelabert vor ein paar Jahren und ich hab mich dann auch nicht mehr drum gekümmert, die haben sich dann auch nicht mehr gemeldet, aber das lag hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich auch daran, weil ich mich nicht mehr gerührt hab, ja, eigentlich wollte ich sogar zu denen gehen, weil ich schon damals ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen hatte mit wer da noch so bei mir im Netzwerk kreucht und fleucht, ja.
Ja, das war wilde Zeiten, da haben die scammigsten Typen YouTube Netzwerke aufgemacht und das war damals auch übelst angesagt, das war Happy, wie hieß das?
Happy Tree Friends oder sowas?
Diese Serien, wo die übelst splattermäßig, diese komischen Viecher da übelst auseinandergesplattert sind immer, war das Happy Tree Friends?
Das war damals voll angesagt, ja.
Irgendwie so ging das doch.
Ich erinnere mich noch dran.
Das ist schon, das war halt so, ich nenne es mal so die Pionierzeit, wenn man das so nennen kann.
Die haben damals, also ich weiß noch, als ich angefangen habe, haben die übelst sich ja rumgedrückt, ich habe damals viele Publisher angeschrieben und Hersteller, so wie sieht es denn aus mit Upload von euren Games, die haben sich entweder gar nicht gemeldet oder sie haben so eine komische nicht-sagende Antwort geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, sie behalten sich ja natürlich alle Rechte vor, das heißt so nach dem Motto, ja, ich kann jederzeit, können sie mich ficken.
Die einzigen, die geantwortet haben, ich habe vergessen, wie hießen die denn, ne nicht Take Two, die gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, THQ, THQ, THQ waren die einzigen, die geantwortet haben damals und die haben gesagt, der Typ, der da geantwortet hat, die haben die einzigen, die gesagt haben, ja das ist auch seiner, das wird wohl okay sein oder so, total random geantwortet, irgend so ein Typ, der wahrscheinlich gar keine Ahnung genau hatte, was ich von ihm wollte, ja also das wird wohl schon okay sein.
Gut, die gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Was bringt einem ein Netzwerk ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel? Das einzige vielleicht, dass man sich nicht so sehr Gedanken um Rechte machen muss, und eventuell mehr Chancen hat mit YouTube in Kontakt zu treten, wenn man mal irgendwie Rechte Probleme hat oder sowas, weil die vielleicht ein bisschen direkt erantrat
hat oder sowas, weil die vielleicht ein bisschen direkteren Draht zu haben, aber ansonsten
muss man ehrlich sagen, außer dass sie ordentlich Kohle kassieren, wobei, naja, mittlerweile
sind es quasi 20% oder so, weiß gar nicht, ähm, für, für recht, man muss ja sagen,
immer noch zu viel für eigentlich nichts machen, ähm, eigentlich bringt ein Netzwerk
nicht so wirklich was, weil ob ich das Geld jetzt von meinem Netzwerk kriege oder von
Google ist, ist ja eigentlich egal, außer dass ich mehr kriegen würde von Google. Theoretisch
machen die ja noch extra, können die ja noch extra Sachen aushandeln für den Channel und
bla und sonst was, aber ganz ehrlich, von allen Netzwerken, wo ich bisher drin war, die
haben eigentlich eher passiv Geld gekrappt und gut war's. So wirklich großartig was gebracht
haben die nie. Und ich hab mich einmal, das war das einzige Mal, wo ich mich wirklich
mich beschwert hab, damals bei meinem Netzwerk, dass die, es war glaub ich das erste oder
zweite Mal, wo, wo wir zusammen auf die Gamescom gefahren sind, das waren damals der, der
Mesh, der Felix, ich und, und, äh, die Freundin von Mesh war noch dabei, genau. So und ich
hab halt gesagt, ok, ich sag denen mal, so wie, wie sieht's dann aus, äh, wir brauchen
zwei, zwei Tickets für die Gamescom, für, für mich und Felix, der Felix, ähm, ist
halt quasi dabei, kann auch die ein oder anderen Sachen aufnehmen und da haben die
einen Riesenakt gemacht, da haben die damals einen Riesenakt gemacht, da hab ich ihnen
halt mal zurückgeschrieben und gesagt, Leute, ihr crappt seit fünf Jahren von mir Geld,
ja, ich hab nie was von euch gewollt, ich hab nie was von euch gehört, ihr habt nie
irgendwas für mich gemacht und jetzt macht ihr wegen so einem Kram einen Riesenakt und
es hat witzigerweise geholfen und wir haben Tickets gekriegt und danach ging's auch jedes
Jahr, bis ich dann keinen Bock mehr auf die Gamescom hatte. Und ich glaub, es geht los,
das, das hat mich damals echt aufgeregt. Weißt du, passiv Geld crappen die ganze Zeit
und wenn du mal irgendwas von denen willst, dann sag du, das wird schwierig.
Was auch übelst gesagt hat, übrigens, nicer, nicer Vegas Grafikeffekt hier, wisst ihr,
was auch gesagt hat bei Machinima? Machinima war so ein großes, die Leute haben Machinima
nicht gesubbt, weil sie dort einzelne Content-Creator sehen wollen, die haben quasi Machinima gesubbt,
um den Machinima-Content zu sehen. Das war ein bisschen, so ein bisschen wie ganz klein
damals diese German-Tater-Geschichte, nur mit dem Unterschied, nur mit dem riesen Unterschied,
dass dort die eigentlichen Content-Creator fast untergegangen sind bei Machinima. Also
sprich, wohingegen dir damals es richtig was gebracht hat, wenn du ein German-Taters-Video
veröffentlicht hast, weil die Leute halt auf den Channel gegangen sind und quasi händeringend
nach mehr Call of Duty, Battlefield und sonst was Content geguckt haben, war es bei Machinima
eher so, die Leute waren schon komplett gesättigt von Machinima. Die haben Machinima gesubbt
und haben sich gedacht, ey, Alter, warum soll ich die original Content-Creator subben? Also
das hat kaum was gebracht, für den normalen Content-Creator bei Machinima zu sein. Ausnahmen
bestätigen die Regel, es gibt bestimmt die einen oder anderen, vor allem, wie am Anfang
dabei waren, aber unterm Strich hat es wahrscheinlich kaum einem was gebracht und man muss auch
sagen, dass die Qualitätskontrolle damals bei Machinima echt fragwürdig war. Ich weiß
noch, wo ich ein Video geguckt habe und ich hoffe, die Feministen haten mich jetzt nicht,
aber das war ein Video von einem Mädel und das war aufgenommen, während sie gerade beim
Mittagessen war. Die hat da gesessen, ich habe hier ein geiles Gameplay-Endspiel, Schreiberklasse,
hat ja dabei gefuddert. Das war nicht so eklig, wie kann man so ein Video hochladen? Alter,
wenn die Leute am Fressen sind beim Video, es ist egal, das hätte auch ein Typ sein
können. Ich weiß halt, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern. So ein Mädel, die hat ein
paar Mittagessen in einem Call of Duty-Video aufgenommen und das haben sie bei Machinima
veröffentlicht. Da habe ich mir gedacht, wo ist denn eure Qualitätskontrolle? Was ist
das denn? Kann doch nicht sein, ich will hier keinen beim Schmatzen zuhören, wie er gerade
versucht Quick zu scopen. Nee. Jetzt habe ich sie übersehen, jetzt habe ich sie nicht
zugehört. Ja, das war übrigens der Grund, warum ich damals auch in den Netzwerk gegangen
bin, weil ich mir gedacht habe, oh cool, ich mache den Kram ja eh, warum kann ich einfach
ein bisschen Geld dabei verdienen? Und es war damals richtig verpönt in ein YouTube-Netzwerk
zu gehen, da könnt ihr euch gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, aber es war damals ein riesen
Ding. Wenn du in ein YouTube-Netzwerk gegangen bist, da haben die Leute gesagt, so nach dem
Motto, Verrat an den Fans, YouTube-Netzwerk, so kommerziell ausgebeutet. Das heißt, Machinima
hat 40%. Boah, das ist schon krass. Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt schon, du hattest damals
nicht die Auswahl. Na, das ist, ist ja nicht, als hätte es Großvater was gebracht. Ahja,
man muss ja sagen, nach heutigen Standorts war das alte Channel-Design nicht wirklich
hübsch. Aber eine coole Sache hatte das alte, und ich meine jetzt nicht das alte und das
alte, ältere, sondern ich meine das wirklich das richtig alte, also dieses da, Channel-Design,
ein Vorteil hatte das, du konntest deinen Channel wirklich cool customisen. Du konntest hier
einzelne Elemente reinmachen, du konntest hier neben Bilder reinmachen, du konntest
hier Bilder reinmachen, du konntest Custom-Inhalt reinmachen, du konntest deinen Channel wirklich
extrem customisen. Heute geht das alles nicht mehr. Und warum geht das heute nicht mehr?
Das ist auch der Punkt, was mich bei vielen modernen Apps aufregt, weil wenn ihr euch
mal angeguckt habt, wieviel Optionen es in Programmen früher gab, wieviel Sachen du
genauso einstellen konntest, wie du wolltest. Guckt euch mal alte E-Mail-Programme an, guckt
euch mal neue E-Mail-Programme an, guckt euch die Firefox-Bedienung heute an, guckt
euch die Firefox-Bedienung von vor 8 Jahren an. Das liegt daran, weil die alle den Scheiß
möglichst low-bob-einheitlich machen wollen, dass es auch der letzte Noob auf seinem Smart
TV von vor 5 Jahren mit Android 30 angucken kann. Unfall die User dumm sind, das kommt
auch noch dabei, ja das stimmt. Machinima ist übelst explodiert. Ja, machinima ist
übelst explodiert. Ja, machinima, Moment, machinima, machinima intro, ich weiß gar
nicht mehr wie das war, aber sobald ich sehe, sehe ich sofort wieder. Ja, genau. Ja, genau,
genau, genau. Ja, ja, ja, das war das Machinima Logo, genau. Davon schreibt Intervention,
ja. Ja, ja, das ist das was ich am Anfang gemeint habe, die Leute haben machinima subscribt
und haben nicht irgendwie versucht die Leute danach zu subscriben, weil ihnen das schon
komplett ausgereicht hat. Und ich glaube, dass Machinima damals auch die eigentlichen
Content Creator gar nicht richtig fördern wollte bzw. auch gar nicht richtig promotet
hat unter den Videos. Bin mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, wie die Videobeschreibung aussah,
aber ich bin mir relativ, also ich bin mir da relativ sicher mit der Vermutung, dass
der Content Creator nicht direkt oben stand, so bspw. hier Video Creator subscriben oder
irgendwie sowas, weil wenn man sich mal genau überlegt, hatte Machinima ja noch gar kein
großes Interesse dran, weil was passiert, wenn Machinima einen Typ hat auf dem Channel,
der auf einmal dann eine Million Abos selbst hat, der macht dann ja keine Machinima Videos
mehr. Die wollten ihre Content Creator Army haben und alles abgreifen, die hatten kein
Interesse daran, dass der größer wird. Das haben die uns damals auch erzählt, aber
da war ich glaube ich schon zu alt, da habe ich das schon glaube ich mal zumindest halbwegs
durchschaut, dass das alles dummes Stonks gelaber ist ohne was dahinter. Der Lost kann
euch da Storys erzählen von komischen Events, die die Netzwerke veranstaltet haben, damals
mit den Außenseitern und sonst war so übelste Cringe Events und so. Der hat da dran teilgenommen,
ich hatte da damals keinen Bock drauf, ich bin nicht die Wester, ich gehe nicht auf
Real Life Events und mir war damals schon klar, dass das alles Gamshit ist. Von Leuten, die
ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung haben, was sie machen. Das war nämlich damals auf YouTube
so, die ganzen YouTube Netzwerke, die Typen die die YouTube Netzwerke gegründet haben,
für die war das erstens wieder 6er im Lotto und die hatten selbst keine Ahnung was sie
gemacht haben. Viele von denen sind wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich reich durchgeworden, ein
paar mit Sicherheit, aber ein paar die es gescheit gemacht haben. Für viele war das
wie so ein 6er im Lotto und sie hatten eigentlich gar keine Ahnung was sie da machen.
Jetzt habe ich dem Typ gar nicht zugehört, was hat er dann erzählt?
Ja, Machinima macht einfach nicht das was sie gesagt haben. Und Machinima hat selbst
keine Ahnung. Oh der Dude, Alter. Die gibt es ja heute noch. Aber der hat auch ein paar
ganz merkwürdige Dinge abgezogen. Ich könnte jetzt nicht mal ein Finger drauf legen was
da war, aber der Name der erzeugt bei mir im Hinterkopf noch so ein paar Ausrufezeichen.
So, bis jetzt haben wir die goldene Fassade von Machinima erzeugt. Was es den Kreatoren,
der Versuch der Glorie und Rechte, Geld für Videos, die sonst nicht monetisiert werden
werden können. So, die Infos vão wissen.
Die Packages, die sie angeboten haben, waren eigentlich viel mehr zereptitious, als sie auf dem Boden kamen.
Die insidiöse Sache von Machinima war, dass sie auf den kurzen Terminen der individuellen Schauspieler geredet haben.
Sieben Jahre! Ein Sieben-Jahres-Vertrag! Auf so einer Plattform wie YouTube, Alter! Sieben Jahre! What the fuck! In sieben Jahren sind auf YouTube-Channels entstanden, haben geboopt und sind wieder gestorben! Sieben Jahre! Okay, meiner mal außen vor. Meiner dumpelt ja schon, weil ich keine Videos mache. So, sieben Jahre!
Fuck, Alter!
Drei Jahre sind, drei Jahre sind auch extrem viele!
Ja.
Was?
Ja, ja.
Lass mich raten. Der Talent-Scout hat nicht ein Finger krumm gemacht.
Ja, genau so habe ich mir das vorgestellt.
Ja.
Das ist richtig.
Dieses Bild wird ja mittlerweile auch gerne gebraucht für alles mögliche, ey.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, Talent-Scouts und so Gelaber hatten die bei uns im Netzwerk auch.
Einmal alles Blödsinn.
Das Einzige, was die wollen, ist möglichst easy money abgreifen von deinem Content.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob es den noch gibt. Gibt es den noch?
Tatsächlich. Okay, aber den guckt keiner mehr. Krass.
Ich hab' gar viele Leute geguckt damals.
Ja.
Was soll das so wie bei dir? Mein letztes Video hat 35K nach zwei Tagen, Alter.
Ja, so sieht's aus. Das entdeckt sich auch so mit meinen YouTube-Netzwerkerfahrungen von früher.
Nicht ganz so schlimm, wie das. Aber da waren auch viele unfähige Leute unterwegs.
Ist so. Muss mal kurz was trinken.
Ja, an Maschine mal erinnert man sich natürlich.
Was hat mein letztes Video für Views? Ich hab gesagt 35K. Ich weiß es gar nicht genau, um ehrlich zu sein.
35K? Kannst du nicht über...
Fucking Battlefield 3 Video in 2021 von einem Channel, der sechs Jahre kaum was in der Richtung gemacht hat.
35K nach zwei Tagen. Easy.
Generell kann ich mich über die aufrufen und dann nur wirklich nicht beschweren.
Kannst dir echt nichts sagen. Guck dir das mal an. Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Huge.
Excellent.
So.
Muss noch ein Schnee-ASMR-Video machen. Alter, ich mach kein ASMR-Video.
Ich mach ein ASMR-Video nach dem Face-Reveal.
Wobei, ich könnte zumindest ja so teasen nach dem Motto, wenn ich es schaffe bis Ende des Jahres 300K, dann mach ich ein ASMR-Video.
Dann kann ich dann geile Flüster-Sounds machen und dann Flüster-Tapping-Sounds.
Alter, huge ASMR-Video hier. Massive Ear-Licking-Videos.
Genau.
Guck mal auf, das ist so abartig teilweise, was es auf YouTube gibt.
Und wisst ihr was das Verstörenste ist bei dieser ganzen Geschichte?
Bei den ganzen Channels, die irgendwelche Ear-Licking-Videos machen.
Jetzt wer das nicht kennt, sucht nicht danach. Es ist wirklich hochgradig verstörend.
Die haben alle in der Beschreibung noch einen OnlyFans-Account, wo dann nicht nur Ears gelickt werden.
Das schauen sich Leute an, ja ja.
Und nicht so wenige, sonst könnten die nicht auch noch OnlyFans-Contents verkaufen.
Katos, ja das ist der Werdegang von vielen, da hast du recht. Patreon-OnlyFans-Many-Wits. Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Ich will es jetzt eigentlich nicht ansprechen, weil ich habe mich ja schon mal darüber ausgelassen.
Chat, hat jemand von euch zufällig das Belldelfin-Video gesehen?
Ich habe mir das rein zu Research-Zwecken mal angeguckt, weil ich gucken wollte, ob das wirklich diesmal das ist, was er gesagt hat.
Und mal ganz im Ernst, das ist das schlechteste Porn aller Zeiten.
Ernsthaft, das ist so dermaßen schlecht.
Also, mir tut wirklich derjenige leid, der dafür Geld bei OnlyFans ausgegeben hat.
Das ist wirklich richtig schlecht gewesen, richtig schlecht. Übrigens eklig, Alter. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das schafft.
Und irgendwie, die sieht mittlerweile echt aus wie der lebende Snapchat-Filter. Ich kann mir da nicht helfen.
Es sieht permanent aus, als ist ein Snapchat-Filter über dem Video drüber.
Na ja gut, was auch immer.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die haben Geld für Wasser ausgegeben.
Da gab es doch den Typ auf YouTube, der das analysiert hat und festgestellt hat, dass in Gamer Girl Badewasser überhaupt keine Hautpartikel drin sind.
Und deswegen das kein Badewasser sein kann.
Exposed.
Angeblicher. Was? Angeblicher. Okay, das Video ist bestimmt wieder Scam.
Wir hatten schon ein paar Videos von ihm, wo er das in Titel geschrieben hat und sich eine Minute mit dem Thema beschäftigt hat.
Mal gucken, ob er uns wieder scammed.
Okay, ich sehe, das Video hat mit dem eigenen Titel nichts zu tun.
Exzellent.
So, was muss ich machen?
Okay, was, was, was, was gehen wir uns jetzt? Eine Runde.
2020 gab es ein paar völlig irre Easter... Der Titel.
Aber eins muss man ja sagen, ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, die GameStar ist die beste Zeitschrift und das beste Gaming-Magazin, was wir haben.
Aber von der GameStar ist auch schon einiges cringe irgendwie. Am schlimmsten finde ich, wenn sie alles eindeutschen.
Also am schlimmsten, also wirklich, eines der Sachen, die mir am meisten im Kopf hängen geblieben sind, war beim Test zu, frag mich nicht, was war Diablo 3 oder so.
Da haben sie irgendwie geschrieben, die wilde Monster hat's gekehrt zurück.
Da habe ich wirklich heart pains jammed, als ich das gelesen habe.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was waren denn die besten Easter Eggs? Die wilde Monster hat's.
GameStar Monster hat's. Oder was? Sacred? Oder was? Sacred?
Die wichtigsten Tipps für Crytek's Monster hat's. Monster hat's ist ein beliebtes Wort bei der GameStar.
Da müsst ihr euch mal, achtet mal drauf, die GameStar schreibt gern was von Monster hat's.
Die GameStar hat so einen Tick dazu, vieles einzudeutschen.
Na hat's, das kommt von hetzen, von schnell vor sich her treiben.
Also das, was man quasi auch, was die Jäger im Wald machen, da wird gehetzt so.
Ja, machen das die Jäger im Wald. Gibt's was Neues bei How to Twitch Chat? Leider nicht.
Grill. Grill Commentator. Exzellent.
Das aktuelle Serious Sam haben sie auch schon hart verkackt, ne?
Was für ein Park?
Okay, im Prinzip sind die Maps eh egal, weil die Maps sind alle scheiße. Und das wird nur noch von Piccadilly übertroffen, weil das ist die scheißigste Map. Schlechter geht's nicht mehr.
Oh nein.
Das haben die, wisst ihr was ich mittlerweile, ich bin ja da schon vorgeschädigt. Ich glaube mittlerweile, dass die solche Sachen gar nicht mehr in das Spiel einbauen, weil das funny ist oder weil sie Leute belohnen wollen, die sich viel mit dem Spiel auseinandersetzen.
Das einzige, warum, der einzige Grund, das ist alles berechnet mittlerweile. Das ist alles Stonks. Das ist alles Stonks Berechnung. Die bauen mittlerweile sowas in die Spiele ein, damit YouTuber drüber machen kann, YouTuber und Content Leute Videos drüber machen.
Oh mein Gott, unglaubliches Easter Egg in Modern Warfare gefunden. So habt ihr Modern Warfare noch nie gesehen. Ihr schießt, ihr glaubt nicht, was als nächstes geschieht. Oh mein Gott, dieses Spiel noch nie da gewesen.
Deswegen bauen die sowas ein mittlerweile. Nicht irgendwie aus, einfach weil es fun ist, vielleicht weil die Entwickler Spaß haben wollen, sondern mittlerweile rein aus Berechnung für sowas. Völlig irre, ja.
Warum gucken die hier, warum gucken die hier Kinder unter den Rock? Was ist hier los?
Das sieht doch eher aus wie Hamster, nicht wie Mäuse. Guckt euch das mal an. Das sind kleine, dicke Hamster. Peter ist informiert, ja.
Kannst du noch mal sagen, völlig irre Chat, völlig irre. Ich bin schon ganz verwirrt. Völlig irre.
Captain Peng fragt, was ist das für ein Easter Egg? Ja, völlig irre ist das. Aha.
Das weiß Infinity Ward selbst, äh das weiß Infinity Ward selber nicht. Wie gesagt, solche Dinge werden nur eingebaut, dass irgendwie die YouTube Leute darauf reagieren können mittlerweile.
Ich bin zum Glück bisher dran vorbeigekommen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Was ist das für ein Game? Ist das Watch Dogs? Nee, nee. Ach, Tony Hawk, okay. Wusste ich gar nicht, dass es da was Neues gibt. Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Watch Dogs vom Hipster-Faktor her. Also man sieht schon mal, dass irgendwas nicht stimmen kann, wenn du ein Hacker-Game und ein Skateboard-Game was so den Character-Design und Hipster-Faktor angeht verwechselst.
Allerdings muss man sagen, Skateboard ist ja überhaupt nicht mehr hip. Heute fahren ja nur noch Boomer wie ich vielleicht Skateboard oder so. Die zwischen Boomer und Zoomer liegende Generation fährt Longboard und die richtigen Hipster-Farmen fahren Elektroroller.
Na geil. Jetzt Klopapier.
Ja, weil die Leute blöd sind und nicht im Internet bestellt haben. Es hätten einfach alle im Internet bestellen müssen. Easy. Einfach zu irgendeinem Großhändler gehen und easy Klopapier bestellen.
Boa. Mooh. Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh, Mooh. Ein Geheimnis mehr Sinn. Sekunde. Muss ich mich vielleicht mal anschauen.
Abloh zu muh sound
Ist er so schlecht gewesen?
sind dazu gehört definitiv das ist boomer games das müsst ihr nicht kennen auch das cool level in diablo 2
ein all-time klassiker den jeder kennt und der mittlerweile sogar von anderen spiel zitiert wird ein easter egg zum easter egg sozusagen
eines der aktuellsten beispiel dafür finden wir in minecraft dungeon nachdem wir das action rollenspiel durchgespielt haben erreichen wir bei
eine schritte war der minecraft dungeon noch mal
das war nicht minecraft singleplayer das war was anderes
Ach das war diese diablo abklatscht da ja ja ja ich kann mich wieder erinnern
war das gerade der icq sound lucht eine kirche mit einem rudenaltar was meinst du
insgesamt neun runden müssen wir finden die sich irgendwo in den verschiedenen leveln des spiels habe nichts gehört die level
prozedural generiert sind und da mit dem zuverlässigen gibt es keine genaue standort position spürnasen sind also wieder gefragt
mit den neun runen im gepäck kehren wir zur kirche zurück und betätigen den goldenen block in der mitte des altaus
dadurch gelangen wir in einen neuen raum der zwei truen und eine schriftrolle enthält die kuhs haus
die brauche ich nicht auch noch jetzt ich habe schon so viel so viel schwachsinn sounds bei mir hier mittlerweile drin und weil ich so
selten sehr selten bringen kann ich möchte keinen speziellen ansprechen aber ich muss mal den sound wieder spielen
Fick dich weg du homo fürst, sonst gastriere ich dir die eier
einfach mal passt überhaupt nicht aber wir hatten so selten gelegenheit dazu
schaltet das geheime level frei über die karte können wir uns nun jederzeit zum cool level
teleportieren wie schon in diablo 2 greifen uns hier wildgewordene rinder an und warten auf eine abbreite
und kinderfreundliche die spricht es auch noch so geil aus du homo fürst
auch wenn 2020 ein turbulentes java über eines konnte man sich sicher moment das war das war nicht turbulent das war das war die
2020 jahres hat es in games die logik
wieder massig easter eggs versteckt haben und genauso kam es dann auch
du mit an ist nicht nur ein hervorragender shooter geworden sondern auch ein fest für easter eggs spürnasen
für eines der besten geheimnisse müssen wir euch wird es überraschen wieder eine schnitzeljagd erledigen dieses mal sind es 14 floppy disks
zumindest werden die level nicht zufällig
ausgewürfelt deswegen kann man sich zum glück im internet informieren wenn man
Schwierigkeiten hat die datenträger die auch ein paar cheat codes freischalten zu finden
haben wir alle floppys aufgesammelt müssen wir zum pc im hauptquartier des doom slayers
zwei benühpunkte erscheinen wovon einer ein vertrautes cover zeigt wenn wir es anklicken können wir tatsächlich das allererste
du mit allem was dazugehört spielen
das war aber noch nicht alles wenn wir den zweiten menü punkt anvisieren verlangt das spiel von uns ein password
das rätsel lösung ist der name flint tegert der den nachfolger freischaltet
der will kann also in eternal die ersten beiden du spiel okay das finde ich tatsächlich ganz cool
komplett durchspielen drei spiele zum preis von einem
spiel wenn sie gefällt
der protagonist habe einfach nur sinnloses zeug ob ich den romane falls ihr euch das gefragt habt ihr habt noch nicht genug
okay dass du mir ist der eck das ging ich würde nicht sagen dass es ein völlig ihres abgedrehte sie ist der eck ist aber das ist das
ist schon gut gemacht gut wir nämlich auch nicht in der
leute ich muss jetzt mal was zu den zu kontrollen los wenn ihr wisst dass ich riesen fan von remedy games bin ich habe alle gespielt
von max payne eins angefangen
max payne zwei ellen wake quantum play ich glaube das war sogar alles so viel so viele haben die ja gar nicht gemacht also die hatten eindeutig eher
quality statt quantity bei bei remedy
Kontroll konnte ich nicht spielen kontroll fand ich mega langweilig total
auch story hat mich nicht gekämpft sorry war im prinzip das warum du remedy games gespielt hast
da muss ich sagen ellen wake hast du jetzt nicht gespielt wegen dem geilen gameplay oder so war das war schon naja
jetzt nicht das geilste gameplay überhaupt mit der taschenlampe rumlaufen ab und zu ein bisschen ballern
aber
generell hat mich die story sowohl beim explain 1 2 3 er war nicht mehr von remedy wobei ich finde er ging auch
und gerade ellen wake übelst gekätscht ja aber kontroll
weiß nicht ich habe das glaub fünf stunden oder so gespielt hat mich nicht geschockt
war fand ich langweilig
wobei ich alle anderen remedy spiele richtig gut fand und ich hätte mir eher gewünscht sie hätten ein quantum break nachfolger gemacht
was sie ja nicht machen konnten weil microsoft keinen bock mehr drauf hatte ich kann ich verstehen konnte quantum break war ich ziemlich gut
weil ich sagen muss ganz im ernst die also mir wäre es lieber gewesen man hätte anstatt diese komische serienproduktion in quantum break einfach das game noch
ein bisschen größer gemacht
weil naja serie war jetzt naja also jetzt nicht unbedingt gebraucht aber
aber das spiel an sich war cool
und die story von quantum break war so typische remedy man kann es nicht mehr so gut wie es jetzt war
und die story von quantum break war so typische remedy man checkt es erst nicht story und dann ergibt es alles sinn
hast du half life alex gespielt nee weil ich keine weil ich nicht für ein game eine vr brillen kaufen will
von control the foundation haben sich acht winkelkatzen versteckt
manche der katzen hat man wahrscheinlich schon während des normalen durchspielens gefunden andere sind deutlich schwieriger zu finden
daher wäre auch ein guide mit allen standorten zu empfehlen für alle die das easter egg selbst entdecken wollen
ok also das suchst du dich ja kaputt für die ganze sucherei kann sich aber durchaus sehen lassen wir müssen dazu den kartenbereich
collapse department aufsuchen und in den riesigen schwarzen raum mit den betonbrücken gehen
dort begrüßen uns die aufgesammelten winkelkatzen und weisen uns den weg in einen weiteren raum
der behärbeck noch mal mehr porzellan stubentiger die im gleichklang ihre pfüllchen
porzellan stubentiger das ist auch so eine schöne game star rede wendung das
ist ich mein die machen das ja nicht nicht einfach so die machen das schon weil die denken dass
macht das video vom fluss her schöner das man die das ist nicht einfach random die sagen halt ok es ist es ist nicht so schön
für texte wenn sich die wörter wiederholen und so was dann macht man halt einfach mal porzellan stubentiger da draus
ihres anführers zudem gibt es für die spielfigur noch ein neues accessoire in form von katzenohren
entwickler remedy bleibt sich auf jeden fall treu darin uns immer wieder mit neuen absurditäten zu verwirrten
als dark souls ersatz macht mortal shell einiges her die kämpfe spielen sich satt der schwierigkeitsgrad ist
ich muss mich jetzt mal outen ich habe von diesem spiel noch nie was gehört
kennt ihr das also ich sehe und höre den namengrad zum ersten mal und das game unnachgiebig und die atmosphäre bleibt die ganze zeit über düster melancholisch
na obwohl die ganze zeit stimmt so ja nicht
im startgebiet des spiels gibt es einen einsiedler mit dem jeder reden sollte der mortal shell in rekordzeit durchspielen will
um mit ihm ins gespräch zu kommen müssen wir dem kaos zunächst eine ratte zum essen und danach ein bisschen alkohol bringen
haben wir seinen hunger und durst gestillt fragt uns der mann ob wir beste freunde werden wollen
all die gefahren da draußen könne man doch gemeinsam ignorieren und einfach nur sein kurzes leben in ruhe genießen
wenn wir auf sein angebot eingehen startet eine zwischensequenz
unser held spielt am lagerfeuer gitarre während die kamera über die spielwelt fährt und schließlich eine schwarzplatte die credits einleitet
herzlichen glückwunsch
wir haben mortal shell beendet das ist tatsächlich eine gute idee
gestorben zu sein denn das mal immer so einfach wäre
das ist ein bisschen
könnt ihr euch noch an far cry 4 erinnern wo du den typ am anfang erschießen konnte ne warte mal
ne moment moment ne ne ne stimmt gar nicht du konntest warten in far cry 4 am anfang
du konntest in far cry 4 am anfang einfach viertelstunde warten und da war das game vorbei ne
ja das fand ich auch das fand ich aber echt gut das fand ich echt gut gemacht
weil es zu der generellen story auch irgendwo gepasst hat
weil auch wenn ich far cry 3 cooler fand
und ich immer noch der Meinung war es ist sogar ein bisschen kurz gekommen in far cry 3
da hätten sie ruhig ein bisschen mehr mit machen können aber
das fand ich in far cry 4 eigentlich cool gemacht
dass der eigentliche böse in dem sinn gar nicht so wirklich der böse war
das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut
warum wäre es dann vorbei weil der typ am anfang in far cry 4 dich ja einlädt
dass du sein nachfolger wirst
spoiler sorry leute far cry 4 spoiler spoiler für 8 jahre altes game oder so
aber ähm
oder 7
7 jahre altes weiß ich nicht wie lang
aber der typ lädt dich ja ein dass du sein nachfolger wirst
so und das kannst du kannst du quasi dann zustimmen und ablehnen oder was auch immer und
ähm der sagt am anfang
hier warte hier auf mich ich bin gleich wieder da
und wenn du das halt nicht machst geht das spiel los
und wenn du das machst wenn du auf ihn wartest dann sagt dann erzählt er dir halt das was er dir später auch erzählt im spiel
und ähm das ist vorbei
far cry 2 mochte ich nicht far cry 1 ist so so in meinem herz ist far cry 1 immer noch das beste
weil far cry 1 das originale far cry ist von crytek
und ähm
es wird ja damals auch ein bisschen gehatet weil es diese komische alien mutanten segmente hat far cry 1 aber ich fand das richtig cool
ähm und far cry 3 hatte wenn man ehrlich ist mit far cry 1 immer all zu viel zu tun
far cry 2 ging schon Richtung open world oder war schon open world und war auch nicht mehr von crytek
das erste far cry das war richtig cool
man entdeckt ja eindeutig die parallel inzwischen far cry 1 und crisis 1
also man crisis 1 ist eigentlich far cry 2 wenn man es so will
klassische rollenspiele sind ja seit ein paar jahren wieder angesagt
so ist es auch kein wunder dass mit wasteland 3 dieses jahr bereits die zweite fortsetzung des apg klassikers und fallout ideengebers erschienen ist
wie es sich für die postapokalypse gehört gibt es in wasteland 3 wieder viel zu entdecken
darunter auch eine ganze menge seltsamer orte mit noch seltsameren figuren
da wäre zum einen das casino und bordell little vegas
das wird von einem gewissen farren by go geleitet der natürlich eine anspülung auf den chef des entwicklerteams brian fargo ist
ok hätte ich nicht gewusst
eine ziege die ihre dienste für 10 dollar verkauft
wenn ich ziegen in einem videospiel sehe
da muss ich an den an den wie ist der simulator ich habe schon wieder vergessen
das ding hieß der ziegen simulator da
wie hieß denn das ding noch mal
goat genau goat simulator
ich bin gerade nicht drauf drauf gekommen ja klar goat simulator wie denn sonst ich sage schon ziegen simulator
natürlich ist das ding nicht ziegen simulator sondern goat simulator
auch so ein ding ist damals jeder let's player rauf und runter let's blade hat und gesagt hat
wie funny und geil und lustig das ist der goat simulator
und ich hab das spiel gestartet weiter nicht viel gekostet und hab mir gedacht ok
das ist so ein spiel was krampfhaft versucht halt
funny zu machen aus dingern die nicht funny sind
ich weiß viele fanden es lustig ich fand es dumm
boomer markt versteht keine witz ich weiß
wollen die uns erzählen dass in diesem game ziegen gebankt werden oder was
was da peter dazu sagt
was ist da los
anzeige ist raus
die hätten die entwicklung mal ein bisschen ernst nehmen sollen
der ballerbuden serie der wieder stumpfen humor der ballerbuden serie
das ist kein far cry 3 ending far cry 4 ending
als far cry 4 ending wenn du am anfang wartest guck mal das da
das ist der anfang wo du im bus bist dann dann dann geht der bus kaputt
so dann kommst du beim oberbösewicht raus bei ihm hier
so und dann sitzt du mit ihm am tisch und er sagt zu dir warte kurz
warte kurz dann geht er weg
so
und jetzt wartest du einfach er sagt warte kurz bis ich wieder da bin oder sowas sinngemäß
und normalerweise wenn du willst das wenn du das game normal spielen willst gehst du halt raus und spielst das spiel
aber wenn du zwölf minuten wartest dann kommt er wieder
dann kommt er wieder und das ende ist dann
der abspann kommt und das game ist vorbei
am ende des ersten kapitels kommen wir beispielsweise an einem stadium vorbei wo gerade ein super geheimes fußball match stattfindet
crowteam die mache hinter serie sam haben zwei teams gebildet die jetzt irgendwie versuchen den riesigen fußball ins tor zu buxieren
das ist ja fast besser wie rocket league esport
man sollte nur kein fifa oder pass erwarten sondern mehr ein chaotisches f-jugendspiel mit mitspielern die nur dem ball hinterherrennen
beenden wir dieses video mit einem wirklichen monster von easter egg
die battlefield reihe hatte ja schon immer geheimnisse die so komplex und verworren waren dass nur eine community von mehreren millionen fans sie lösen konnten
und mit einem der letzten patches für battlefield 5 hat dice ihrer community nochmal eine solche aufgabe gestellt
tatsächlich sind teile des easter eggs schon seit über einem jahr im spiel zu finden aber erst jetzt
massive aim massive aim der dude hier gerade an tag gelegt
tatsächlich sind teile des easter eggs schon seit über einem jahr im spiel zu finden
aber erst jetzt kann man das easter egg und seinen exklusiven skin auch wirklich freischalten wir müssen zunächst im hauptmenü den folgenden code angeben
bindestrich
darauf hin hören wir das bekannte battlefield themen und die map the challenge erscheint in der kartenauswahl
zusammen mit drei weiteren mitspielern müssen wir auf der karte einen sehr hohen punkt im himmel erreichen indem wir zusammen eine treppe bauen
dafür müssen wir zunächst verschiedene gnome finden die uns den weg weisen
wenn wir den hinweisen folgen sollte jedes unserer squad mitglieder
moment gabs die gartenzwerge nicht schon mal in einem anderen battlefield
moment oder war das left for dead?
in welchem spiel gabs gartenzwerge?
das kommt mir bekannt vor
nicht sims
sims
es gab doch ein spieler heisman mit so ne half life 2
ich kann mich noch dran er konnte den gartenzwerg aufnehmen und hatte den gartenzwerg dann in der hand und da hatte ich die ganze zeit so doof angeguckt
was macht daraan
war das left for dead?
nee
Ich kann mich nicht mehr, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, es gab ein Game, da konntest du den Gartenzwerg aufnehmen, da hatte ich so doof von der Seite angeguckt.
Ja, das war doch Left4Dead, genau, wusste ich doch noch.
Ja, genau, das meine ich, das war Left4Dead mit dem Gartenzwerg, genau, da hatte ich die ganze Zeit so doof angeschaut, das hat sich bei mir irgendwie eingebrannt.
Das war Left4Dead mit dem Gartenzwerg, genau, besser als Fortnite, oder?
Ja, übertreibt DICE, äh.
Obbei das ja nicht wirklich ein Easter Egg ist, das ist eher so ein, das ist ja schon eine ganze Mission.
Klar, letztendlich geht es darum, dass es geht, nicht so sehr, was man dafür als Belohnung kriegt.
Also ich finde, das größte Easter Egg 2020 war, dass Max FPS wieder ein Video hochgeladen hat, falls ihr den kennt.
So, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Ja, vier Phantom Mission, da kann ich mir überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Kein Weihnachtsstell, ja, da warte ich ja auch noch drauf, dass er mal ein Video aus dem Garten wieder aufnimmt.
Modern Warfare und Xbox, Still Alive, Zeit mal her. Wisst ihr, was ich witzig finde, Fortnite hat auch keinen Bock mehr auf Black Ops.
Der hat am Anfang, äh, hallo, YouTube?
Der hat am Anfang hier recht viele, recht viele Cold War Videos gemacht.
Und danach hat er sich gedacht, scheiß auf das neue Game, ich spiele die alten einfach weiter.
Ja komm, wir gucken, wir gucken ne Runde, gucken ne Runde, der macht immer nice Videos.
Ich kann MW3 aufm PC übrigens noch spielen, hab ich letztens gesehen, Video mit Custom, fragt mich nicht, Custom Server Browser oder was das ist.
By the way, stimmt ihr hier wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht, ne?
Moab? Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, da ist die Moab Videos.
Warum finde das?
Ok gut, jetzt haben wir uns auf das Video eingestimmt, das können wir gucken.
Da sollte mal einer irgendeinen Remix draus machen.
Boah, Z-Town war das glaube ich. Das war das letzte Call of Duty, wo ich die Maps noch halbwegs kenne.
Die Gegner sind doch genauso planlos wie früher.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, dass tatsächlich wenn du Black Ops 1 und MW2 spielst, hast du heute noch bessere Chancen eine Lobby zu finden als MW3.
Der ist Host, der ist, guck mal, guck mal wie gut der Host, der ist Host von der Lobby, oder?
Guck mal, der ist das Host, so wie der hittet, also wurde es direkt instant hitted, ohne Verzögerung, wobei, ja wahrscheinlich ist er Host.
Die alten Teile hatten Host-Vorteil des Todes, Black Ops 1 war fast unbesiegbar als Host.
Er war doch nicht Host.
Du weißt nicht, ob du Host-Nachteile hattest in MW3, du hattest auf jeden Fall auch viele Host-Vorteile.
Nein, Black Ops 1 hatte auf der Konsole, das war alles P2P.
Oder um genau zu sein, war es nicht P2P, sondern jemand hat auf seiner Xbox halt den Server gehostet.
Moab, da ist die Moab, da ist die Moab.
Am PC konntest du Server mieten in Black Ops 1, ja, du kannst es ja sogar heute noch spielen, aber da gibt es ja glaube ich bloß noch 5 Nuketown 24.
Das ist die Moab.
Erstmal weggequickscoppt, noch nicht mal gequickscoppt.
MW3, weiß ich nicht, ob es einfach auf PC gab, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das war ja mal eine lange Zeit Running Gag.
Kennt ihr noch dieses Video von mir, wo ich...
Seht ihr noch das Video von mir, was ich mal gemacht habe damals zu Call of Duty 2015, da habe ich mich auch lustig gemacht über Dedicated Servers.
By the way, das Video habe ich mal mir gelöscht, das hat jemand anderes hochgeladen wieder.
Kennt ihr das noch? Das fand ich eigentlich übelst lustig, das müssen wir jetzt nochmal gucken.
Das ist ja die Wahrheit, das ist immer noch so, was meint ihr, warum es Skill-Based Matchmaking gibt?
Das erzählen sie ja heute noch, das hat sich die letzten 5 Jahre nichts geändert.
Ja, es ist immer noch so, es ist immer noch so.
Ist heute auch noch so, ist heute auch noch so. Was, Chat ist im Weg? Ist der Chat echt im Weg?
Ok, Moment, ok Leute, ich mache den Chat kurz aus, dass wir das in voller...
Ok, ok, jetzt. Es ist halt immer noch so. Ja, es ist immer noch so.
Hey, guckt euch Cold War an, das ist halt einfach nur, was heißt nur, nur den Modern Warfare Reskin, das merkst du an allen Ecken und Enden.
Das Original kennt auch fast jeder. Vor allem, es ist halt überhaupt nicht lustig für Leute, die Spanisch können.
Für Leute, es ist genauso wie diese ganzen Untergang-Videos, Hitler Reacts. Kennt ihr die? Die sind ja im englischsprachigen Raum voll angesagt, Hitler Reacts 2.
Und es ist halt auch nicht lustig, wenn du es auf Deutsch guckst, weil du verstehst halt, was die sagen.
Der Angriff Steiner ist nicht erfolgt und in den Untertiteln steht dann irgendwie sowas drin, wie die neue GTX 1080 Tiggy ist gerade erschienen.
Es geht halt nicht, wenn du Deutsch verstehst.
Das erzählen sie doch wirklich jedes Jahr. Jedes Jahr erzählen sie den Kram.
Ist auch so, ist auch so, immer noch so. Ist halt auch noch so, wo die ganzen Leaks-Videos immer herkommen.
Das machen die Hardcore-Fans immer noch.
Cool, ob das doch so ist, keine Ahnung. Xbox-Exklusiv sind sie nicht mehr.
Natürlich.
Okay, das muss man sagen. Modern Warfare war auf dem PC schon okay.
Das haben sie ja wirklich erzählt.
Ja, es sind Modern Warfare auch so.
Natürlich.
Das ist nicht mehr so.
Das hat jetzt tatsächlich so halbwegs funktioniert.
Ich habe das Video gelöscht, weil damals war das noch nicht so krass verbreitet.
Es war schon verbreitete Meme-Geschichte, aber nicht so extrem.
Und damals hat der originale spanische Fernsehsender noch Leute, die das Video verwendet haben, richtig hängen geblieben.
Mittlerweile machen sie das nicht mehr.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter im Video rein.
Okay, Puppke ist nie fertig geworden.
Die Raser aller mp7 wegsprayt.
Das habe ich mich damals schon immer gefragt bei den Leuten, die die Multiplayer gespielt haben.
Warum gibt es so viele Leute, die einfach random auf der Map stehen und nichts machen?
Was?
Gab es da einen Perk, dass Claymores nicht auslösen?
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Moment.
Ah, das ist das Terminal Remake in Modern Warfare 3.
Das hat mich gerade sehr verwirrt.
ACR, beste.
Poggers Waffe.
Da wollte er ihn wegstölzen von hinten.
Ist der jetzt gerade gestorben?
Das war komisch geschnitten.
Jim, das ist einfach 1-2 als Terminals MW2.
Posty Moab.
Guck mal, da sitzt er.
Er hat gekotzt, zeige ich euch.
Das ist die Map, wo ich dieses Video darüber gemacht habe, dass MW3 ein brutales Killerspiel ist.
Und die Leute haben das damals geglaubt.
Man sieht, die Leute damals online waren auch nicht cleverer als die meisten Leute heute online.
Mangos wären dankeschön für die 4 Monate Subscription IQ++ hier für den Chat wieder.
Ah, das G18 ist sehr schlecht. Ich habe dieses Spiel schon lange nicht genutzt.
Das G18 ist sehr schlecht. Ich habe dieses Spiel schon lange nicht genutzt.
Marksman.
Ich habe noch die Attack-Insertion da unten.
Das tut weh, oder Kumpel?
Ich habe schon 19 Töne, ich muss mich umdrehen.
Specialist.
Oh, fast aufs Maul gekriegt.
Scarce Silenced, auch Poggers Waffe gewesen in dem Spiel.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, im Nachhinein mochte ich MW3 gar nicht.
MW3 war das Game, was mir so ein bisschen den Spaß daran verdorben hat.
Danach habe ich ja, ich habe Black Ops 2 dann noch gespielt.
Ghosts ganz kurz und dann hatte ich eigentlich keinen Bock mehr.
Okay, wir gehen, wir gehen, wir sind auf dem Weg. Nicht zu groß, aber wir sind auf dem Weg, wir nehmen es.
Ich sehe seine Waffe.
Die Lobby sind ziemlich schwer in MW3 zu kommen.
Also habe ich etwa eine Stunde gewartet für diese.
Ebenso keine Überraschung.
MW3 auf Xbox ist wirklich kein Wettbewerb.
Ich versuche einen Moab zu bekommen, aber ich habe eine Chance,
jede Stunde einen Moab zu bekommen, wenn die Lobby nicht kaputt geht.
Ich glaube, ich will wieder auf PC gehen.
Wow, ich bin irgendwie noch lebendig.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich tot hier.
Die MW3-Experienz ist so viel mehr Spaß.
Die IW-5, das Plutonium, was auch immer.
Ich wollte nur sehen, denn ich habe die IW-5 nicht auf meinem neuen PC installiert.
Woher kommst du denn her?
Wir beginnen dort. Einen Killstreak.
Das ist großartig.
Okay, wir müssen diesen Typen töten.
Ich habe ihn.
MW2 war richtig farbenfroh dagegen.
Glücklicherweise gucken die Gegner nicht hinter sich.
Der Gegner wollte einfach den Kopf geschossen kriegen.
Er hat einfach gewartet, bis er ihn weghaut.
Wo ist die Moab?
Nicht gut.
Einfach rein sprayen.
Reinsprayen ist der Weg, zu gehen.
Ich habe ihn durch die Wand getroffen.
Ich brauche einen Backup.
4400.
Ich dachte, ich komme nahe zu nichts, aber...
Ich bin zurück.
Ich habe hier 100.
Warte mal.
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Irgendwo hier.
Auf dem portable Radar.
So, Moab.
Auf geht's.
Knapp, knapp, knapp.
Gab es nicht ein schneller Recken-Perk?
Mit Specialist?
Alter.
Der hatte doch einen Perk, dass ihm die Granate nicht so viel ausmachen, oder?
Wie die Granate runterrollt vor ihm.
Guck mal hier.
Die ist direkt vor ihm runtergerollt und explodiert.
Da ist die Moab, Leute.
Die Moab.
Und jetzt muss er kreisen und messen.
Also es gibt zwei Regeln in Call of Duty.
Wenn du eine Moab, eine Nuke, eine Cam, was auch immer kriegst.
Du musst messen.
Und du musst dich im Kreis drehen, wenn du sie zündest.
Wenn sie einschlägt.
So, messen.
Ah.
Okay, es ist zur Hälfte valid.
Das ist zur Hälfte, zur Hälfte valid.
Er hat gemessert, er hat gemessert.
Okay, okay.
Aber eigentlich hätte er sie noch zu 16 müssen.
Okay, nicht schlecht.
So, jetzt gucken wir noch in der Battlefield.
Jetzt haben wir uns MW3 anguckt.
Das ist richtig Oldschool-Scheiß.
Jetzt gucken wir uns noch mal ein bisschen top.
Ob wir diesmal in dem Video dabei sind.
Weil wir haben ziemlich viel Battlefield 3 gespielt.
Teilweise sogar Onstream.
Und ich habe recht viel auch Offstream gespielt.
Mal gucken, ob wir drin sind.
Mal gucken, ob er Venice-Gameplay drin hat.
Oder nur Official.
Schauen wir mal.
Den mache ich übrigens jetzt nicht so laut, weil er sagt eh immer das Gleiche.
Und ich laber die ganze Zeit drüber.
Warum ist das Video so dunkel?
Sind es Sniper auf deinem Team?
Ich sehe viele Dinge.
Auf dem Turm, ich weiß nicht, ob sie auf dem Turm sind.
Ich habe nur 1.100 Meter Sky Recon.
Auf einem Mann, der in deinem Spot sitzt.
Okay, das war jetzt schon zu 90% Glück, aber der wollte den wenigstens treffen.
Ich finde diese random Clips, wo random irgendwie was gehitted wird, immer nicht so geil.
Aber was ich halt cool finde ist, wenn man sieht, ja klar, es ist Glück, aber der wollte den Typ hitten.
Und er hat ihn gehitted.
Ich habe mich noch nicht mit Servern beschäftigt.
Ich habe bis jetzt noch keine Zeit gehabt. Heute auch nicht.
Ich muss heute noch ein Video aufnehmen.
Ja, so ist halt das Influencer-Content-Creator-Life.
Keine Zeit für nichts.
Bam, in den Kopf, Alter.
Sag mal, warum stehen die alle AFK auf der Map rum?
What the fuck?
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Wo guckt der Sniper hin?
Da ist nichts.
Da ist nichts, gar nichts.
Der guckt vielleicht, ob die Ecke vom Haus einer kommt oder so, aber der guckt eher dahin.
Naja.
So gibt es bei Venice wenig, ganz so planlos, ja.
Oh, Metro-Spray.
Ist das von mir?
Ist das Xbox?
Leute, ist das Xbox?
Von der Auflösung her und dem Gepixel könnte das Xbox sein.
Was ist? Alter!
Alter, was ist mit Mina los?
Der Typ ist an Mina vorbeigelaufen und die guckt nach dahinten.
What the fuck?
Was bin ich sehend, Alter?
Guck mal!
Da!
Da steht er!
He doesn't know he lacks critical information.
Ups.
Ich wollte stehen einblenden.
Ist das PC?
Alter, was muss er auf dem PC?
Auf der Xbox hätte ich es ja noch verstanden, aber auf dem PC?
Rammer-TV, jawoll.
Ram.
Ram-Szene.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
Cool.
Das ist ein cooler Clip.
Das war ein bisschen was ausgefallenes.
Mit dem Heli.
Das ist schon mal nice.
Und jetzt macht er noch die...
Der Typ!
Die sind so blind.
Oh Gott, Alter!
Man erkennt es nicht am Skin,
man erkennt es über diesen fetten roten Balken
über dem Kopf, ob ein Gegner ist.
Am Skin erkennt man es theoretisch auch,
aber da guckt keiner drauf.
Ah, schön M16-Spray.
Oh, die Granate geht dick.
Dick gekillt jetzt.
Ja, Gegner in...
Oh, wie es sich wegschmeckt.
Nice.
Ja, so lasse ich es.
So, das war es.
Ja, so Lineups ist natürlich poggers.
Wenn sie sich da wegsprayen lassen.
Dann, wenn das rote Label nicht angezeigt wird,
dann kannst du es erkennen, weil es kein blaues Label hat.
Du erkennst eigentlich Battlefield-Gegner immer.
Oh.
Das ist ein guter Clip.
Es ist OP-Waffe und die Gegner lassen sich
auch krass wegsprayen, aber
dumme Gegner gehören immer dazu.
Das war ein echt tolles Killstreak. Wir haben hier ein paar perfekt geplanten Momente.
Dieser auf dem Damavant Peak ist genau das, was du in den Tunnels sehen willst.
Mit dem M98B lineiert.
Das ist zumindest ein Triple.
Folgendes davon haben wir ein paar...
Der Panzer, der Panzer fährt ihm einfach vor die Nase.
Ja, ja, die wird was der APG.
Ich hab's im Green.
Prost.
Ja, okay, das war auch ein bisschen...
ein bisschen sehr glücklich, ne?
Okay.
Hä?
Wo ist das letzte M kommen?
Ah.
Oh. Moment, das hab ich...
Moment, das muss ich jetzt... Das hab ich überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Sind da gerade drei Gegner einfach
random hintereinander gelaufen mit dem Kopf?
Ja.
Kommt nicht.
Und noch mal in den Kopf, nice.
Oh.
Double Headshot mit der Magnum.
Nice.
Moin Sebaro.
Ich find's komisch, dass keine Venice Clips dabei sind.
Da geht doch eigentlich viel mehr grad ab.
Als zumindest interessantes.
Okay.
Massive Highskill Clip.
Geradeaus in die Öffnung sprayen.
Oh, oui, oui, oui.
Oh, wie keiner auf ihn schießt.
Leute, please.
Dreht euch mal in die Richtung.
Ihr könnt ihn doch gar nicht sehen.
Ja, da schießt jetzt die Wand runter und er macht Platsch.
Okay.
Wenn das nicht Konsolen-Grafik ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Klar, das ging.
Du konntest in Battlefield 3.
Das ist eigentlich gerade auf Bazaar gang und gäbe.
Auch auf Zen Crossing.
Der LRV ballert immer erstmal die ganze Mauer weg.
Leute, so haben wir damals gespielt.
Und das ist auch noch entweder mit einer Kamera abgefilmt.
Mit einer Kamera abgefilmt.
Oder mit einem richtig miesen Crabber für die PS3.
Haha.
Lul.
Alter, sieht das scheiße aus.
Bäm, bäm.
Rex, beste Waffe.
Und jetzt messern.
Jawoll.
Nein, das sind keine Franzosen.
Das sind nämlich Japaner, oder?
Oder was ist das für eine Sprache?
Nein, oder Chinesen sind das.
Keine Ahnung.
Die Map haben wir gestern gespielt.
Diese Map.
Die emcom-Platzierung ist ja so ppiger.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Du.
Du wirst das nicht erwarten.
Ja gut, das ist Nintendo, das darf man nicht vergessen.
Heißt Max in vor immer noch Q-Chat oder Informatiker?
Ja, entweder heiße ich Max, Q-Chat oder Informatiker in VU.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, man kann sich in VU nennen wie man will.
Das heißt es gibt auch einige Fake Leute, weil ich habe schon gehört,
dass ich angeblich rumgeflogen wäre über die Maps und Munitionskisten getroppt,
die explodiert sind.
Was ich nicht habe.
Ohne Scheiß.
Die könnten diese Voice Lines von Battlefield 3
überhaupt gar nicht mehr heute bringen.
Die sagen da so Sachen wie
Cocksuckers are here
oder I get fucked in the ass, I get drilled in the ass hole.
Das sind so Dinge, die die Voice Samples von Battlefield 3,
wenn das heute in dem Game rauskommen würde,
die wären alle extrem gedriggert.
Also Ranon, gestern sollte ich gekickt werden.
Gestern auf Metro wollte einer, dass ich unbedingt gekickt werde,
weil ich einen zu guten Ping habe.
Kein Witz.
Gestern hat einer auf Metro gesagt,
die sollen mich kicken, weil mein Ping zu gut ist.
Nicht weil der Ping zu schlecht ist.
Der Ping war zu gut.
Der hat mir ernsthaft gesagt,
ich soll gekickt werden, weil ich einen zu guten Ping habe.
Dabei hatte ich noch nicht mal den besten Ping im Team.
Ich hatte glaube ich 18, 19, 20 so rum,
dass Ebaro teilweise 12 hatte, habe ich gesehen.
Captain Bär hat 11 richtig hängen geblieben.
In Wirklichkeit steht der Surfer bei mir im Keller.
Ich will es refunden.
Und Hit. Hit. Nee.
Die treffen hier auch nichts.
Das Zeug zu treffen ist nicht ohne.
Was ist das für eine Map gewesen?
Ich habe es nicht geguckt.
Golf? Golfo Forman ist das.
Golf. Sorry. Golf. Nicht Golf. Golf.
Ich glaube schon.
Was? Bandai Desert? Quatsch.
Golfo Forman ist das mit diesen Krähen.
Echt ist das Bandai Desert?
Okay, Chat, ich glaube euch mal.
Ich glaube euch mal.
Ja, tatsächlich stimmt, die Schiffe gibt es da nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich, ja, ihr habt Recht.
Ja, ab und zu muss der Chat ja auch mal Recht haben.
Nach so vielen Subs und Massive IQ Improvements
muss der Chat ja irgendwann auch mal Recht haben.
Irgendwann ist es so weit.
Okay, ich gebe zu, das Stöße nicht Golfo Forman ist Bandai Desert.
Alles klar. Big Brain Chat.
Too smart.
Der schießt jetzt den Pilot raus. Jawoll.
Das Vorhalten von Schüssen ist irgendwie total inkonsistent in Battlefield 3.
Man muss so ein Stückchen vorhalten, man muss so ein Stückchen vorhalten.
Nicht so ganz 100% predictable.
Manchmal hittet es auch nicht, obwohl es hittet.
Was ist das für eine Auflösung?
Das bestimmt ehemaliger CS Pro, der denkt, die Köpfe werden größer, wenn er das so macht.
Quick Scopter, No Scopter, den Heli Pilot.
Okay, das ist echt krasses Glück.
Seinen normalen Scop trifft er überhaupt nicht.
G3, schon wieder so ein Typ, der einfach rum steht.
G3 müsste ich auch mal wieder auspacken.
G3 hatte, glaube ich, mit einer der höchsten Bullet Damage im Game.
Es ist geplant, dass es mit Monarch S weiter geht, ja.
Ich habe das bei mir im Einsatz, es funktioniert wunderbar.
Ich musste es nur noch fertig machen. Nur, nur noch.
Gab es da auch Extended Magnet? Nee, das wäre zu OP gewesen.
Ja, Sebaro, man muss natürlich treffen dafür.
Da war ich verreckt, weil ich versucht hätte, den noch mal zu facen.
Alter, die PP-Gas, was ist denn hier los?
Was ist denn hier los?
Thanks for watching this episode of Only in Battlefield.
If you did enjoy, feel free to leave a like down below.
You can also find players' channels in the description.
Best of subscriptions.
Especially the streamers, give them some support.
Thanks for watching and I'll catch you in the next video.
Zeig mal her, ich krieg Hunger.
Ja, kommt hin von der Uhrzeit.
Ich krieg langsam Kohldampf. Was gucken wir jetzt noch?
Super Mario Odyssey New World Record.
Battlefield Bad Company.
Das haben wir doch schon mal gesehen, das BC2-Video von Jack Frax, oder?
Bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher.
Komm, da gucken wir das jetzt.
Das ist immer schon kurz und eigentlich auch ganz gut gemacht, die Videos von ihm.
Auch wenn er jetzt öffentlich-rechtlich ist.
Und ohne Mist, der Typ erinnert mich von der Sprechweise so krass an Willi Pete Cars.
Als wär's der Typ, ne?
Ah, da kann ich mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Da kann ich mich noch ganz...
Da kningelt's bei mir im Kopf noch irgendwie, wenn ich den Namen höre.
Ja.
Ich glaub, die sind ja schon dicht mittlerweile, ne?
Guckt der jetzt einfach nur kritisch oder hat er keinen Bock?
Die guckt schon!
Da kriegst du ja mit der Angst zu tun, Alter.
Ist das ein neues Intro oder hat er das schon eine Weile?
Wir danken an dieser Stelle dem Journalisten John Careyrew.
Er hat mit seiner atemberaubenden Investigativrecherche enorm dazu beigetragen,
dass die folgende Geschichte ans Licht gekommen ist.
In seinem Buch Bad Blood erzählt er sie sehr spannend und ausführlich.
Bücher lesen 2021, Alter.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Sie hat eine visionäre, vielleicht sogar weltverändernde Idee.
Es geht um einen neuen, besseren Bluttest.
Ein kleines Gerät, das anhand von nur weniger Tropfen Blut
hunderte Diagnosen treffen könnte.
Man kann sich Anzeichen tödlicher Krankheiten frühzeitig erkennen und behandeln.
Der Gedanke ist genial.
Eine solche Technologie könnte unzählige Leben retten.
Gleichzeitig wirkt die Idee utopisch.
Bisher braucht man für solide Tests relativ große Mengen an Blut und ein Labor.
Holmes scharrt Wissenschaftler um sich und gründet im Jahr 2003
das kleine Biotech-Unternehmen Theranos.
Innerhalb kürzester Zeit sammelt sie 6 Millionen US-Dollar.
Das ist ja bei den Amis normal.
Dass da Investor wird ohne Ende in der Hoffnung, dass sich das mal auszahlt.
Und die Leute, die da investieren, die rechnen...
Ich weiß nicht, ob die gescampt werden wollen, aber die rechnen wahrscheinlich auch schon mit,
dass vieles davon in die Hose geht.
Aber dafür, da wo es sich halt rechnet, ist es sich halt hundertfach rechnet.
Um sich in der Männerwelt des Silicon Valleys behaupten zu können,
baut Holmes sich eine eindrucksvolle Persönlichkeit auf.
Sie trägt jeden Tag denselben Steve Jobs Rollkragenpulli
und redet an einem ungewöhnlich tiefen Bariton.
Das ist doch Fake-Stimme, oder?
Die hatte doch vorher eine ganz andere Stimme.
Die Stimme hat sie bestimmt auch gefaked.
Sie wissen sogar, dass sie ein grundsätzliches Menschenrecht haben,
um sich selbst Informationen zu bekommen.
Holmes verlangt von ihren Mitarbeitern, dass sie rund um die Uhr arbeiten.
Sie selbst schläft nur vier Stunden pro Nacht und isst Kaffeebohnen, um sich wach zu halten.
2007 steht es schließlich der Prototyp, Edison, benannt nach dem großen Erfinder.
Ein gigantischer Durchbruch, wie es scheint. Das Unternehmen wächst jetzt wahnsinnig schnell.
Mit jeder Investitionsrunde fließt mehr und mehr Geld in die Firma.
Es geht um Dutzende Millionen.
Kann man nicht mehr per Handy subben, doch relativ, oder?
Wobei, es könnte sein, dass die da irgendwas gemacht haben,
weil Apple zu viel abwollte, aber ich bilde mir ein,
ich konnte letztens noch vom Handy subben.
Kostet aber mehr, als ich würde vom Desktop subben.
Oder, du nimmst einfach deinen Prime-Sub, da kostet es gar nichts.
Falls ich das nicht heute schon erwähnt habe.
...Riesen Walgreens ab.
Der plant Wellness Center in seine Filialen einzubauen, gespickt mit Theranos Produkten.
Dort sollen Kunden ihr Blut günstig und schnell testen lassen können.
Ja gut, wenn du nur einen Tropfen brauchst für 300 Diagnosen,
dann ist das natürlich eine gute Idee, aber das wird halt so nicht funktionieren.
Später tritt Theranos mit seinen Innovationen an die Öffentlichkeit.
Die Presse lobt das Unternehmen in höchsten Tönen.
Im Aufsichtsrat der Firma sitzen alte Staatsmänner wie Henry Kissinger und Jim Mattis.
Unglaubliches Prestige.
Holmes selbst wird mit Steve Jobs oder Bill Gates verglichen.
Was man daran wieder sieht, ist, dass da gerne überschwänglich gelobt wird,
bevor überhaupt jemand irgendwas gemacht hat.
...landet auf der Titelseite der Magazine Fortune und Forbes.
Letzteres beziffert ihr Vermögen auf 4,5 Milliarden Dollar.
Ist das so?
Der Wert ihres Unternehmens beträgt zu diesem Zeitpunkt 9 Milliarden Dollar.
Die wollen ja auch teilweise gescampt werden.
Obama lädt Holmes zum Dinner ein.
Time erklärt sie zu einer der 100 einflussreichsten Personen der Welt.
In den ersten Walgreens Filialen werden die neuen Wellness Center geöffnet.
Aber, hm, die Theranos-Geräte scheinen irgendwie nicht zu funktionieren.
Immer mehr Walgreens-Kunden bekommen erschütternde Bluttestergebnisse.
Oh, ja, oh, fuck.
Stell dir mal vor, oh, das ist ja, das ist ja richtig krass.
Also, wenn das Ding einfach nur nicht funktionieren würde,
wär ja schon scam genug.
Aber wenn das Ding Diagnosen stellt, die überhaupt nicht stimmen,
stell dir mal vor, du bist, keine Ahnung, 25,
top in Form, gesund, gehst in so einen Wellness Center und sagst,
ach ja, nehmen wir mal ein Ding Blut, aber das kommt dann an wie, keine Ahnung,
Gehirntumor, alles Mögliche, komplett vorbei leben.
Sie haben noch sechs Monate zu leben.
Alter, WTF?
Oder, das ist wie bei mir, wenn die sagen würden, ich bin schwanger.
Mathe, drei, vier Monate Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich hab noch irgendwas übersehen gerade mit Subscribers.
Ich muss mal kurz in meine, in mein Dashboard gucken.
Ey, RealShade hatten wir davor.
Ey, hab ich schon gesehen.
Danke schön für den Sub. Ich hab alle gesehen, passt.
Teenagern droht angeblich ein Schlaganfall.
Einige Patienten werden aufgrund fehlerhafter Ergebnisse
unnötigen Behandlungen unterzogen.
Das ist ja richtig fail, Alter.
Eine schwangere Patientin hätte ihr Kind verlieren können,
wenn ihr Arzt dem Theranose-
EM312, danke schön für den Sub.
Ergebnis vertraut und sie dementsprechend behandelt hätte.
Das ist ja heftig, ey.
Das ist ja richtig, ich mein, wie gesagt,
wenn das Ding einfach nur nicht geht,
dann, ähm, einmal so.
Was, wie, sieben Euro kostet das zusammen, ernsthaft?
What the hell, was ist mit Twitch los?
Trotzdem, exquisite Subscription, danke schön.
Du kannst glaub ich auch im Safari aufmachen Twitch
und über Safaris sammeln, dann geht's nicht über einen Appstore
und kostet nur fünf Dollar, oder fünf Euro.
Ergebnis vertraut und sie dementsprechend behandelt hätte.
Dollar, Dollar sind's, ne?
Was ist da los?
Es funktioniert nicht, ist da los.
Ein Schritt zurück zum Edison Prototyp 2007.
Das Gerät hat nie richtig funktioniert.
Sieht aus wie ein Toaster.
Ein junger Wissenschaftler, der später zum Whistleblower wird,
um die Neuigkeit der Theranos-Maschinen testen.
Er untersuchte denselben Tropfen Blut mehrmals
und erhielt jedes Mal andere Resultate.
Man schrieb ihm vor...
Okay, da ist einfach ein Randomizer drin.
Das Ding hat einen Text-File mit 300 Diagnosen
und randomize dann einfach daraus.
Randomint.
Unerwünschte Datenpunkte sollte er löschen.
Ah, so macht man seriöse Forschung.
Journalisten über Jahre hinweg gefälschte Ergebnisse gezahlt.
Die wollten sich auch...
Da gehören immer zwei dazu.
Einer, der genug Energie hat zu scammen
und Leute, die sich auch scammen lassen wollen.
Weil ich gehe mal davon aus,
hätten die mal wirklich sich ein bisschen Expertise eingeholt
und auch von Leuten, die sich auf dem Gebiet auskennen
und hätten die gefragt, okay, wie schätzt ihr das denn ein?
Kann das funktionieren?
Dann hätten die ihnen gesagt, ne, es gibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Genauso wie dieser Wasser.
Könnt ihr euch noch an diesen Kickstarter erinnern?
Mit diesem Ding, was in der Wüste Wasser im Boden aus der Luft...
Wie war das?
Aus der Luft in der Wüste Wasser filtert
und dann Trinkwasser für alle Menschen bereitstellt und so was.
Ich hab schon vergessen, wie es heißt.
Das Ding kann aber allein schon vom Ansatz her nicht funktionieren.
Wie kann man Leute finden, die sich scammen wollen?
Guck mal an, Comedy-Gruppe.
Das sind alles Leute, die sich scammen lassen wollen.
Die gibt es in allen Lebenslagen, Altersklassen
und mit Geld oder ohne.
Das, was sie gemacht hat, ist im Prinzip
die Extended-Variante von Comedy-Gruppe.
Comedy-Gruppe ist für die Low-Prains auf YouTube.
Und das war der Scam für Leute mit Geld.
Ihr zappt hier doch auch.
Ihr zappt ja nur, weil ihr von Twitch in den Subtrain gescampt wurdet.
Vielleicht, ich will es nicht ausschließen,
vielleicht, bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
vielleicht zappt auch der eine oder andere,
weil ihm das Stream gefällt, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist schon ein gutes Anzeichen für,
wenn was nicht richtig läuft.
Das kann man, so denke ich,
für alle Arbeitgeber und alle Jobs sagen.
Wenn die Leute Angst haben müssen,
was Kritisches zu sagen,
und ich meine jetzt mit kritisch nicht,
alter Chef, kack Spaß, piss dich alle,
sondern was ordentlich formuliert ist.
Wenn die Leute Angst haben müssen,
was Kritisches zu sagen,
um ihren Job haben müssen,
wenn sie was Kritisches sagen,
dann stimmt mit dem Laden irgendwas nicht.
Trotz all dieser Unstimmigkeiten,
gelanges Homes über Jahre hin...
Die sieht übelst vampirmäßig aus.
Guckt die euch mal an.
...wiedergefeuert.
Trotz all...
Boah, das sieht übelst...
Da habe ich Angst vor.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr liegt im Bett,
ihr macht die Augen auf,
und auf einmal habt ihr sowas vor euch.
Ihr erschreckt euch doch des Todes.
...dieser Unstimmigkeiten,
gelanges Homes über Jahre hinweg,
immer größere Investoren,
um zu entwickeln
und einen unfassbaren Hype zu kreieren.
Bis der anfangs erwähnte John Kerry Rue
das Kartenhaus zum Einsturz bringt.
Er trifft sich
mit ehemaligen Mitarbeitern
und Mitarbeiterinnen von Theranos
und rekonstruiert das Geschehen.
Als Homes von seiner Recherche erfährt,
übt sie enormen Druck
auf die Whistleblower aus.
Jetzt wird erstmal Anzeige ist raus.
Dennoch veröffentlicht das Wall Street Journal
die Recherche am 15. Oktober 2015
auf der Titelseite.
Ja, jetzt ist vorbei.
Moment, das ist der Typ, der sie interviewt hat, oder?
Das ist doch der gleiche Dude,
der das Interview vorher gemacht hat.
Und jetzt kann er sagen, Leute, jetzt wisst ihr auch,
warum ich so kritisch geguckt hab damals.
Ich wusste schon immer.
Die Protagonistin
streitet erstmal alles ab.
Dieses dumme Gelaber!
Das, das
müssen alle Stonksleute können. Einfach nur
dummes Gelaber und dabei so
aussehen, als müsste man, bevor man spricht.
Und das ist doch
auch garantiert nicht ihre normale Stimme.
So spricht doch keiner. Die hat eine
tiefere Stimme als ich. Gut, das ist jetzt
keine Kunst.
Aber als Frau ist es doch
nicht so häufig.
Und das ist auch so was,
wo man genau erkennt,
sobald jemand
versucht zu scammen. Scammer
sagen nie was falsch ist.
Die sagen nur immer, man weiß das doch
oder es ist falsch.
Es ist doch allgemein bekannt. Mit
Menschenverstand erkennt man, dass es falsch
ist. Oder umgedreht, wir haben
Recht. Wir hatten schon immer Recht. Wir wussten
auch von Anfang an, dass wir Recht haben. Die sagen
nie was genau ist.
Daran, dass
es auch so ein Ding, was bei allen Scammern
immer so ist. Die sagen nie was genau falsch
ist oder warum, was genau
sie jetzt quasi,
was aussagt, dass sie Recht haben.
Das ist bei allen Scammern so.
Okay, das ist keine
Fehlerquote. Ich würde eher sagen,
es ist Glück, wenn die mal das Richtige hatten.
Natürlich hast du unqualifiziertes
Personal, wenn du willst, dass die 24-7
arbeiten. Kein qualifiziertes Personal
arbeitet 24-7 oder
ist definitiv nicht mehr lang
qualifiziert, wenn sie lange 24-7 gearbeitet
haben.
Tja.
Die Amis fackeln mal
sowas nicht lang.
Die gucken schon so. Alter,
da kriegst du mit der Angst zu tun.
Oh.
Ja.
Ohne Mist, das kann sein.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Es gibt ja manchmal so auch das Problem,
dass wenn du erst mal angefangen hast,
Scheiße zu erzählen, du quasi
irgendwie gezwungen bist, immer weiter
Mist zu erzählen.
Also was da genau gelaufen ist,
man weiß es wahrscheinlich nicht genau.
Kann schon sein.
Die hat auch Schiss gehabt.
Überleg dir mal, wenn du
eine Milliarde
Schulden hast oder noch mehr,
da kannst du nicht von heut auf morgen
sagen, hallo Leute,
Skamast, Skamast.
Die unglaubliche Geschichte von Theranos
zeigt jedenfalls, wie wichtig
es ist, derartiges Unrecht
zu melden und öffentlich zu machen.
Erst diverse Whistleblower
haben verhindert, dass Theranos
noch viel mehr Schaden anrichten
konnte. Genauso braucht es
mutige Journalisten wie John
Careyrew, die zuhören und nachforschen.
Man weiß ja nie, welche
angebliche Milliardärin,
welch angeblicher Milliardär
sich alles ausdenkt.
Cheers.
Echt so.
Deswegen
es gibt
so eine einfache Regel,
die öfters
als man denkt zugrifft,
wenn was zu gut klingt, um
wahr zu sein,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich nicht wahr.
Und damit
wird man wahrscheinlich zu 99%
richtig liegen.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal ein bisschen was,
nicht ganz so ernst. Wir gucken mal,
wie er wieder in 20 Sekunden einen
Schlock, einen Schlock,
das ist die Kombination aus Lock und Schloss.
Also wie er in 20 Sekunden
irgendwie einen Schlock öffnet.
Schlock.
Das ist eine gute, gefällt mir,
das sollte ich mir patentieren lassen.
Name für eine neue, für einen neuen Schlock.
Kokona, nicht Kokona,
Kikomas-Lock.
Ich muss den lauter machen übrigens.
Okay, ich predicte jetzt mal was passiert.
Der nimmt irgendwie so ein billiges Stück Metall,
wackelt dreimal da im
Schlock rum und
das ist offen.
Wusstet ihr das ICQ
aus It's Russen gehört?
Was meinst du, Sebaru?
Ich habe nichts gehört.
Warte, warte, warte.
Was?
Moment, was?
Moment, was so?
Das hab ich jetzt nicht kapiert.
Geiles Schloss!
Da ist ja ein Schloss, was du über Wish bestellst besser.
Easy!
Der Typ ist aber auch echt gut, ey.
Ich glaube, es gab nur ein Schloss bisher, was er nicht aufbekommen hat.
Und das war das deutsche Schloss.
Was gar kein Schloss war, sondern nur aussah wie ein Schloss.
Weiß Smart Home Upgrades.
Den Typ guck ich immer ganz gerne.
Und der ist jetzt umgezogen und zeigt jetzt, was er bei seinem Smart Home wieder neu aufbaut.
Mal gucken, was er jetzt aufbaut.
Geht ja nur 5 Minuten.
Und im Zweifelsatz kann ich mich über Kokona-Häuser lustig machen.
Bist du irgendwann mal dein Gesicht zeigen?
Ja, werde ich.
Bei einer Million Abos auf YouTube.
Oder, oder, oder, oder, aber dauerhaft.
Keine Ahnung.
2.000 Subs auf Twitch.
Da muss ich nämlich nicht mehr vor die Haustür, da kann mich keiner mehr erkennen.
Easy.
Was ist das?
Das ist doch kein Haus.
Ist das eine übergroße Garage oder was ist das?
Das ist doch kein Haus, Alter.
Das ist Kokona-Haus.
Die Amis, Alter.
Die Amis.
Das ist...
Letztes Mal ernsthaft, das ist doch kein Haus.
Das ist ein Gartenhäuschen vom Material her oder so.
Das wenigstens Wände?
Nee, oder?
Das ist einfach Haus mit Dämmmaterial.
Das ist Holz mit Dämmmaterial, ne?
Na gut, ein Vorteil hat's, ein Vorteil hat's.
Wenn man beispielsweise so Schalter in die Wand machen will, ist das ganz einfach.
Da nimmst du eine Säge, du machst ein Loch in die Wand und steckst das rein.
Das funktioniert in Deutschland ja je nach Wand und je nach Stein nicht sonderlich gut.
Deswegen haben die auch alle so einen Wirbelsturm und Tornadokeller.
Weil in dem Haus kannst du da nicht drinnen bleiben.
Einfach Löcher in die Decke machen.
Ich mein, es hat bestimmt auch seine Vorteile. Ich denke gar nicht mal, dass das alles schlecht ist.
Wenn du jetzt beispielsweise in einem Gebiet bist, wo du jetzt nicht dicke Fette heizen musst, ist das eine Sache.
Wenn ich glaube, Häuser gut heizen, weiß ich nicht, ob das, je nach Dämmmaterial,
könnte sogar wahrscheinlich ganz gut funktionieren.
Und es geht schnell und es ist wahrscheinlich deutlich günstiger als ein Haus bei uns zu bauen.
Also das hat sicherlich auch seine Vorteile ja.
Das ist aber auch Kokona Wiring.
Boah, wie viel Lichter macht der denn?
Hast du eigentlich noch Kontakt zum Friseur? Klar. Wir haben erst vor zwei Tagen zusammen bei ihm im Stream gehockt und sein OBS umkonfiguriert.
Okay, das ist langweilig. Das einzige, was ich machen kann, ist, mich lustig machen über Kokona Häuser.
Leute, das zeigt mir nicht böse, aber das geht bei mir nicht als Hausdurchsicht.
Das ist ein Gestell mit Dämmmaterial.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus. War mal einer von euch bei uns hieß das Ferienspiele.
Das war so ein Entertainmentprogramm für Kinder in den Sommerferien.
Und bei uns haben wir in den Ferienspielen immer Holzhütten gebaut zusammen.
So ungefähr sieht das da auch aus. Ohne so viel Verkabelung.
Gut, da gibt es nicht so viel zu sehen. Jetzt ist es langweilig.
Leute, ich glaube ich gehe essen. Ich habe Hunger.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Sub-Sound ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht. Was ist mein aktuelles Sub-Sound?
Ich bin jetzt gar nicht mehr so sicher. Wie könnte man das rausfinden?
Das war er. Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
HG, danke für den Sub. IQ++, ja.
Mal kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Sub's übersehen habe.
Leute, schön, dass ihr dabei wart. Wir haben in letzter Zeit, seitdem ich regelmäßig streame,
immer ordentlich Leute vorbei. Das finde ich sehr nice.
Was ist das?
What the fuck?
So hört sich ein gut gekühlter Computer an.
Okay, langweilig. Alles klar Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Wir sehen uns. Ich mache nachher noch ein Video.
Guck mal, ob ich das heute hochlade. Wäre sinnvoll. Dann lasse ich mich über meine Abschlussprüfung aus.
Die Leute im Stream kennen es wahrscheinlich schon, aber ich erzähle es nochmal für YouTube und besonders ausführlich.
Die ist nämlich echt fail gewesen, meine IHK Abschlussprüfung. Ich bin durchgefallen.
So viel als Spoiler. Aber am Ende habe ich sie doch bestanden.
Was mache ich für ein Gameplay drunter? Ich will nicht immer Battlefield drunter machen.
Ich könnte ja Geralt einfach nur mal rumstehen lassen wieder.
Oder ich spiele drei Runden Cranker I.O. und mache das als Hintergrund.
Nein, Overwatch kriege ich nicht. Kein Overwatch, Leute. Kein Overwatch.
Schauen wir mal. Also Leute. Bis denn, CU. Ach so, Moment. Ist der Fabian vielleicht am Streamen? Den können wir dann hosten.
Nope. Alles klar.
Irgendjemand, den wir hosten können. Ich schaue mal kurz schnell. Irgendjemand von den Deutschen, der es brauchen würde.
Okay, alles klar, Leute. Also ich bin weg. Ich gebe was essen. Bis denn, CU.